COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IT HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICE
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMUNITY-
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WHATSOEVER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
ARE MEMBER PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY IS CENTERED
ALONG MON CELLS ARE AMONG CAN
YOU PLEASE. SAY HI TO US AND
ALSO INDICATE IF YOU HAVE A
SUPPORT STAFF WITH YOU AND- THE
NAME OF THE PERSON WHO IS WITH
YOU IF YOU DO HAVE SUPPORT
STAFF WELCOME. THURMOND THANK
YOU CHAIR YES I AM IN THE
OFFICE AND I HAVE BENJAMIN
PETERSON HERE WITH ME. IN THE
OFFICE. THANK YOU THE REMOTE
CENTER LAMONT. CENTERS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
COULD STICK FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED TO USE THE RAZOR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
WHICH I'LL KEEP. MONITORING
HERE. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ONMUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE%
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN RIGHT
NOW AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE SIX ONE FIVE TWO ONE
ONE AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE SIX ONE FIVE TWO ONE ONE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER. TO THE
SENATE- COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
SIGN A LINE NUMBER AND THIS CAN
BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
UN MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY IN THE
VOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE OTHERWISE WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AS CHAIR I MUST
MAINTAIN I WILL BE MAINTAINING
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IT'S CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. SO TODAY
WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA- AND- ALSO ON ONE OF THE
ITEMS FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY HUESO IS ON
CONSENT. WE WILL HEAR TO BILLS
AND AUTHOR ORDER THE ORDER MAY
BE MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE BILL
ABILITY BILL AUTHORS PRESENT IN
THE NEED TO COMPLETE THE
HEARING AGENDA AND THE TIMELY
MATTER. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILLS DO
WE HAVE OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
M. HAND HERE MELINDA'S HERE.
HERE EGGMAN YOUR- EGGMAN HERE
AND SALAS HERE GONZALEZ HERE
GROW FURTADO LEYVA YOU'RE
LEAVING HERE LIMON. SENATE LIAM
ON HERE LIMON HERE ROTH YOUR
ROTH HERE RUBIO WIENER A WINNER
HERE. ALL RIGHT WE NOTE THAT
THE STILLNESS OF A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED FOR BILL
TESTIMONY DUE TO CONSTRAINTS ON
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED ME INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY
EACH SIDE OF THE PERMIT AN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR. SO
FOR- HEARING HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION L.
PERMIT UP TO TWO WITNESSES. FOR
TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS OR
MAXIMUM FOUR MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE SO PROVIDING EQUAL TIME.
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS DETER
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. I HOPE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY HOWEVER BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A DEFINITE DEFINITE TIME
AND TIME FOR THE HEARING. I MAY
LIMIT THE TOTAL TIME FOR ALL
COMMENTS ON A BILL TO ENSURE
THE COMMITTEES ABLE TO COMPLETE
OUR HEARING AGENDA TODAY TO BE
FAIR TO. EVERYONE EVERYONE ALSO
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO MID
TESTIMONY ON ANY BILL BEING
HEARD ON HEALTH COMMITTE
WEBSITES IF YOU AREN'T ABLE TO
TESTIFY HERE OR YOU WISH TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY THAT
YOU CAN'T GIVEN THE TIME LIMIT.
PLEASE SUBMIT IT TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. SO WITH THAT
LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH THEIR
FIRST AUTHOR SO OUR FIRST ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER ONE SB THREE
SIXTY FIVE BY CENTER CABELLO. I
SEE SHE'S AT THE PODIUM
WELCOME. GO AHEAD PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB THREE SIXTY FIVE.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE MEDICAL TO
REIMBURSE ALL PARTIES
PARTICIPATING PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. FOR ECON SALT
SERVICES INCLUDING THOSE WHO
OPERATE OUT OF IT FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CLINICS WERE
RURAL HEALTH CLINIC. IT CONSULT
SERVICES ARE TRULY A PATIENT
CENTERED INNOVATION. WHEN A
PATIENT HAS A NON URGENT
QUESTION A CONDITION REQUIRING
SPECIALTY CARE. THEY ALLOW ONE
PROVIDER USUALLY A PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER TO SEND ELECTRONIC
CONSPIRED SOLD TO ANOTHER
PROVIDER WHO IS USUALLY A
SPECIALIST. THE SPECIALIST THEN
GIVES THE RESPONSE TO THE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER AND IT
COULD VERY FROM WANTING TO SEE
THE PATIENT IN PERSON. TO
RECOMMENDING A PRESCRIPTION OR
COURSE OF CARE. ECON SOLD
OFFERED TIMELY RESOLUTIONS FOR
PATIENTS WHO MAY NOT OTHERWISE.
BE ABLE TO WAIT WEEKS OR MONTHS
TO SEE A SPECIALIST FOR
SOMETHING THAT MAY NOT REQUIRE
AN APPOINTMENT IN THE FIRST
PLACE. CURRENTLY EACH CONSULT
SERVICES ARE REIMBURSABLE FOR
PROVIDERS AT THE DISTANT SITE
AND THESE ARE USUALLY THE
SPECIALIST PROVIDERS HOWEVER
THE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER AT
THE ORIGINATING SITE IS NOT
ABLE TO BILL. FOR THIS
TELEHEALTH. CONSULT BOTH
PROVIDERS BRING EXPERTISE IN
INFORMATION TO THE TABLE WHEN
DISCUSSING THE PATIENT'S
CONDITION BUT ONLY THIS
SPECIALIST IS REIMBURSED FOR
THEIR TIME. IN FACT IT COULD BE
ARGUED THAT THE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN IS GOING ABOVE AND
BEYOND BY EACH CONSULTATION
WITH THE SPECIALIST. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THE PATIENT IS
EVENTUALLY REFERRED IF THE
PATIENT IS REFERRED FOR AN
APPOINTMENT THE SPECIALIST NOW
HAS BACKGROUND ON THE PATIENT'S
CONDITION. AND THE VISIT WILL
BE WELL SPENT ON NEXT STEPS
INSTEAD OF INFORMATION
GATHERING. AND IF NO REFERRAL
IS NEEDED THEN THE PATIENT WILL
HAVE THEIR QUESTIONS ANSWERED
WITHIN. WITHIN A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME. EITHER OF THESE
OUTCOMES BENEFIT THE PATIENT
MORE THAN A SIMPLE REFERRAL
WITH NO PROVIDER TO PER. TO
PROVIDER CONAND- THIS SHOULD
BE A GREAT BUT TO RURAL
RESIDENTS WERE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE IN GENERAL HAS BEEN A LONG
STANDING ISSUE. IN RURAL
DISTRICTS IT IS DIFFICULT TO
GET AN APPOINTMENT WITH YOUR
GENERAL PRACTITIONER AT THE
LOCAL CLINIC LET ALONE A
SPECIALIST WHO MAY BE HOURS
AWAY. DATA INDICATES THAT MANY
PATIENTS DO NOT SEEK FOLLOW UP
SPECIALIST CARE BECAUSE OF
TRANSPORTATION AND CHILD CARE
CHALLENGES. APART FROM
EVERYTHING ELSE USE OF ANY
CONSULT WOULD DETERMINE IF A
PHYSICAL VISIT IS IN FACT
NEEDED SAVING RURAL PATIENTS
TIME MONEY AND ANXIETY. SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE IS A SMALL
CHANGE TO THE BILLABLE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES IN MEDICAL.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL NOT
ONLY CREATE EQUITY FOR THE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WILL IMPROVE CARE
FOR THE PATIENTS. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. HE'S TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT I'M SORRY MISTER TURNER
IS A DOCTOR WHO IS IN A MEETING
WITH THE CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
FOR COMMENT IN A HEALTH CENTER.
AND ROBBIE FRANCESCHINI POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE BLUE PATH
HEALTH WILL BE ON THE LINE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR JUST TO
CLARIFY IT WAS THE SECOND TO
TESTIFIED JUST FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WAS ALSO GIVING
TESTIMONY YES SEARCHES FOR
TECHNICAL OKAY ALL RIGHT SO-
MODERATE PLEASE BRING- DANIEL
ROMERO- TO. LINES PROVIDE. ON
S. THREE SIXTY FIVE IN SUPPORT.
DAHLE PREMIER THE LINE IS OPEN
ALL RIGHT SO THAT TWO MINUTES
PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN. HELLO
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO JOIN YOU
TODAY TO PRESENT ON SENATE BILL
THREE SIXTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES
FROM MEDICAID TO REIMBURSE
ENROLLED PROVIDERS FOR EACH
CONSOLE SERVICES INCLUDING
ACCURACIES AND ARE YOU SEE. MY
NAME IS WHAT I NEED IS NINE THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF
CAMERON HEALTH AND IF YOU H. C.
WOULD HEALTH CLINICS IN
SEVENTEEN SITES ACROSS FRESNO
AND MADERA COUNTIES WE SERVE
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS
AND ACCOMPLISH APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PATIENT VISITS A YEAR. PART
CLINICS HE CONSUL PROGRAM HAS
BEEN A LIFELINE FOR EXPANDING
ACCESS TO CARE FOR PATIENTS.
PRIOR TO IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM IT WAS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
PATIENTS TO WAIT WEEKS TO
MONTHS FOR SPECIALTY
APPOINTMENTS. THE ADDITION OF
THE CONSUL'S HAS HELPED TO
RELIEVE WAIT TIMES FOR
APPOINTMENTS BY ENABLING OUR
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS TO
ACCESS SPECIALTY INPUT AND
MANAGE THEIR PATIENTS CARE
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR AN IN
PERSON SPECIALTY VISIT. AYE
CAMARENA IN CASES WHERE
PATIENTS RECEIVED ANY CONSUL
ARE PCPS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
MANAGE THEIR PATIENTS WITHOUT
THE NEED FOR SPECIALTY VISIT IN
84% OF CASES. FURTHER OUR
PATIENTS WALKED AND WALKED TO
THEIR APPOINTMENTS AND HAD
DIFFICULTIES WITH MANAGING
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION OR ACCESS
TO CHILD CARE TO ATTENTION
THEIR SPECIALTY APPOINTMENTS
HAVE REPORTED GREATER
SATISFACTION WITH THEIR CARE AT
THE CHALLENGES BECOME
NONEXISTENT IN THIS PROGRAM.
ALLOWING FOR BOTH THE PRIMARY
CARE TREATING PROVIDER AND THE
CONSULTING SPECIALISTS TO BILL
FREE CONSULS WILL ENSURE THESE
CLINICIANS GET COMPENSATED FOR
TIME SPENT ON SERVICES OUTSIDE
OF CLINIC VISITS. SHOULD MY
COLLEAGUES AND MY CLINICS AND
OTHER FQHCS ACROSS THE STATE BE
ABLE TO BILL FOR ECON SOLD
SEPARATELY FROM THEIR CLINIC
VISITS THE STATE WOULD BE
MAKING AN INVESTMENT IN
INNOVATIVE CARE PRACTICES AND
TECHNOLOGY ALREADY IN USE AT
LARGER HEALTH SYSTEMS THAT
SERVE MANY CALIFORNIANS ON
COMMERCIAL PLANS. IN A YEAR
WHERE PARITY AND EQUITY ARE OF
CONCERN TO STAKEHOLDERS AND
POLICMAKERS ALIKE I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY FIVE SB CONSUL AS A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS SERVING OUR. MEDIC
HEALTH BENEFICIARIES THANK YOU.
THANK DR MAY- THAT'S NOW MOVES
TO DIGITAL WHAT. AND SUPPORT OF
S. THREE SIXTY FIVE THE NAME
ORG- ORGANIZATION AND
OPPOSITION WILL BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY. STEINORTH
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SAYING NO
ONE AT ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELEPHONIC WIND
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. TO CALLERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB THREE
SIXTY FIVE AND AGAIN IT'S NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. ADELINE
THIRTEEN YOUR MICROPHONE.
PLEASE BEGIN HELLO THIS IS
CINDY HILLARY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
THANK YOU RIGHT SPENCER ON
BEHALF OF THE OCEAN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WELL I AM
FORTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
THE THROWBACK AND ALSO THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SUCH
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
BLIGHTED FORTY FOR YOUR
MICROSCOPE. SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE ADVENTIST HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE LINE
FORTY SEVEN NEAR MY COULD OPEN.
JOHN WINDER ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS HERE TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. LINE
SIXTEEN NEAR MY COULD OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ERIN MINNELLI ON THE
CITY GENERAL COUNSEL FOR ARREST
AND HE- IN SUPPORT SB THREE
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE THIRTY TWO YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. BOB THIS IS DAN FRAZIER
CEO OF HOW CAN BE. OR OTHER
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. AND MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION THERE IS
NO FEE OF OPPOSITION SPEAKER
LISTED HERE IS THEIR OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY IN THE GALLERY. C.
NINE LET'S ROUTE MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SAYING NONE-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
TO PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SIXTY
FIVE AND AGAIN IT'S NAME
POSITION NAME AFFILIATION
POSITION. ARE COMMON IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR I SHOW
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR NOW LET'S
MOVE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON SB THREE SIXTY FIVE. ENDS UP.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANYONE'S
MICROPHONES UP I DON'T SEE A
HAND UP- SIR CUMBERLAND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- IT DEFINITELY
ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT GAP IN
TERMS OF MAKING TELEHEALTH
WORKING ALSO FOR A BETTER
ACCESS PARTICULARLY ON THE
PRIMARY CARE SIDE WE OFTEN
THINK ABOUT TELEHEALTH AND
NEEDING SPECIALTY REFERRAL BUT
THAT VALUES THE PRIMARY CARE
SIDE AS WELL THAT
COMMUNICATIONS SO CERTAINLY I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATE
GOVERNOR ISER MOTION ON THE
BILL IT'S MOVE BY CENTER EGGMAN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
FIRST REVIEW WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN. HI CAN I MULLIN THIS.
MELENDEZ I. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
AIKEN SALAS HI AND SALAS I GREW
GROVE BY HER TADO. LEYVA ALL
LEYVA HI THE MOON. SENATOR
LIMON SB THREE SIXTY FIVE HI.
LIMON AYE ROSS AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO WIENER BY WIENER AYE.
NINE NINE OKAY THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS NINE VOTES SO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
YOUR NEXT BILL ITEM NUMBER TWO.
SB THREE SEVENTY ONE- PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB THREE SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS
STATUS IS A COMPREHENSIVE
FRAMEWORK WHICH BUILDS UPON
EXISTING DATA EXCHANGE EFFORTS
IN THE STATE. TOWARDS A MORE
ROBUST HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO ACCESS PATIENT
MEDICAL RECORDS AND INFORMATION
IN A SAFE SECURE AND TIMELY
MANNER THIS DATA EXCHANGE CAN
TAKE MANY FORMS INCLUDING
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGES OR
H. I. EASE NATIONAL DATA
EXCHANGE NETWORKS AND APP BASED
EXCHANGES. THESE FORMS OF DATA
EXCHANGE PROVIDE CONFIDENTIAL
ACCESS TO A PATIENT'S UNIQUE
MEDICAL HISTORY REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY GO FOR CARE AND
ALLOWS PROVIDER TO GIVE THE
PROVIDERS TO GIVE
INDIVIDUALIZED CARE BASED ON
THE PATIENT'S HISTORY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A ROBUST
HEALTH DATA EXCHANGE TO ACHIEVE
GREATER CARE COORDINATION AND
VALUE BASED CARE DUE TO GREAT
ADVANCES IN DATA EXCHANGE MOST
PHYSICIANS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CONNECTED HOWEVER MANY SMALL
RURAL AND SAFETYNET PRACTICES
LACK THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
FUNDING TO ACCESS THE SYSTEMS.
WITHOUT THE TECHNOLOGIES THESE
POSITIONS ARE CUT OFF FROM THE
KEY FROM THE EASY EXCHANGE OF
DATA BETWEEN FELLOW PHYSICIANS
AND OTHER PROVIDERS AS WELL AS
THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT DIRECT
PATIENT ACCESS TO THEIR OWN
DATA WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
SB THREE SEVENTY ONE ADDRESSES
NOT ONLY THE VALUE OF THE INTER
CONNECTIVITY HIV BUT ALSO MEETS
THE NEEDS OF PHYSICIANS AND
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES WHERE THEY
ARE ON THE TECHNOLOGICAL
SPECTRUM AND HELPS TO BRING IT
EQUITY TO THE SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY SB THREE SEVENTY
ONE CREATES A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN FOR H. I. E. ACCESS IN ALL
MEDICAL PRACTICES ACROSS THE
STATE BY BUILDING SUPPORT
BRIDGE WHERE IT IS NEEDED FOR
SMALLER ESTABLISHMENTS THIS
BILL ALSO CREATES A STREAMLINED
ACTS THIS. FOR PROVIDERS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH THE- AND
LEVERAGES FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION NEEDS
ADDITIONALLY SB THREE SEVENTY
ONE REESTABLISHES THE ROLE OF
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY OF HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. AND THE
E. HEALTH COORDINATING
COMMITTEE UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TO
FACILITATE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE
AND WITH OUR FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
PARTNERS. WITH THE WITH TH
VITAL COMPONENTS THAT MAKE UP
SB THREE SEVENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
WILL BE ON A FASTER AND MORE
EQUITABLE PATH TOWARDS HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
IS DOT DR STEVEN LANE OF SUTTER
HEALTH AND DAVID FORD VICE
PRESIDENT OF HEALTH IT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
CAPITAL- LET'S MOVE NOW ON TO
THE WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY ONE
SO MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON TO
LINE DR STEPHEN LANE. AND DAVID
FORD AND WILL BEGIN WITH DOCTOR
LANE AT TWO MINUTES EACH- TO
THE FIRE. DR LANE BLIGHTED OPEN
OKAY DR LANE THANK YOU ACTUALLY
WE WERE GONNA HAVE WE WERE
GONNA HAVE A CORD START OKAY WE
CAN DO IT THAT ORDER TO THE
SPOKESWOMAN ALL RIGHT SO- DAVID
FORD PLEASE BEGIN. ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BY DAVID FORD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE OTHER SPONSORS
OF SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY
ONE. WANT TO THANK CENTER
CABALLERO FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THE GOAL OF SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY ONE IS TO
ENSURE TE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO LEAD THE WAY ON HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE. TO DO SO
WE UTILIZE WE PROPOSED TO
UTILIZING NETWORK OF NETWORKS
APPROACH HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. INCLUDING NATIONAL
NETWORKS REGIONALLY GYROS TO
PARTICIPATE IN CALIFORNIA TRUST
EXCHANGE NETWORK AND THE COMING
OUT BASED EXCHANGE. SO THAT NO
MATTER WHICH TECHNOLOGY A
PHYSICIAN OR A PATIENT USES.
THE PATIENT DATA IS AVAILABLE
UP A POINT OF CARE. THE SENDER
MENTIONED THERE ARE SEVERAL
MAJOR COMPONENTS OF THE BILL
REBUILDING STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUPPORTS HIV- ON MICHAEL
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA SO THAT IT
CAN BE ACCESSED AND USABLE
AFTER POINT OF CARE. AND
ACCESSING FEDERAL MONEY FOR
GUARANTEEING THAT THURSDAY BACK
IN THIS PLACE BECAUSE THE MONEY
THAT COMES IN. GETS SPENT
INEQUITABLE MANNER. NOT A PUT
IS IN LITTLE BIT CALM. AND NOT
BEING OUT INTRODUCED DR STEVEN
LANE- BUT OVER THIRTY YEARS I
THINK THE HR AND USER IS A
MEMBER OF THE AUTO INDUSTRY
HIGHLY COUNTY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THE SEQUOIA PROJECT
BOARD OF DIRECTORS THE CARE
QUALITY HEARING COMMITTEE IN
THE HIPS AND PROBABILITY
TECHNIQUES BUT- THE NOW. DOCTOR
MIGHT. THANK YOU FOR MAKING IT
AT A PRETTY. AND CAN- I JUST
WANT THANK YOU CAN FOR THE
OPTIONS SPEAK TO THE DAY. I'M
NOT CAL. RECORDED THIRTY YEARS.
IN CLINICAL PRACTICE AND
INFORMATICS. YOUR ON HELPING TO
EXCHANGE I WAS PREVIOUSLY ON
THE BOARD- AGREE HEALTH
INSPIRATIONAL THE NATION IN THE
TECHNOLOGY LEVEL THE NUMBER OF
NATIONAL. SUPPORTING A BALDING
TECHNICAL STANDARDS AND
OPERATIONAL SOLUTIONS IN
SUPPORT OF HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE SO I RENTED SUTTER
CREEK NEARLY THIRTY YEARS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINE- WE CENTER
EXCHANGE MORE THAN NINETY
MILLION PATIENT RECORDS
ACCORDING TO CARE OF OVER SIX
MILLION PATIENTS- IN CARE
COORDINATION AND TRANSITIONS OF
CARE. WE STARTED THIS EFFORT AS
THE TECHNOLOGY ALLOW EXCHANGING
THE USERS OF THE SAME. VENDOR
EHR BUT THEN WE WERE QUICKLY
ABLE TO CONNECT TO THE
NATIONAL. CHANGE THAT WORKING
CONSTANTLY THE CAREQUALITY
FRAMEWORK ALLOWS EXCHANGE
BETWEEN PROVIDERS USING ANY
SORT OF FIND WORK ON THE CALL
RECORD. TODAY WE LEVERAGES
FRAMEWORK TO STRANGE SIX
MILLION PATIENT RECORDS A MONTH
WITH MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
INDEPENDENT PROVIDER OFFICES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND MY
PRIMARY CARE PRACTICES ACTUALLY
EVERY SINGLE PATIENT BUT I'VE
SEEN AS EXTERNAL INFORMATION
AVAILABLE AUTOMATICALLY IN
THEIR RECORD- LOCALLY AND
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK-
POLITICAL. LITERATURE
CONNECTIVITY TREMENDOUSLY
VALUABLE DURING THE PANDEMIC
ALLOWING US TO CHANGE COULD BE
TESTING OF THAT SCENE
INFORMATION. FASTER WE ALSO
WERE EARLY ADOPTERS OF NEW THE
NEW GATE EXCHANGE MODELS
UTILIZING APPLICATION
PROGRAMMING INTERFACE WHICH
APPLE HEALTH IS REALLY
OBLIGATED TO ALLOW PATIENTS
ACCESS TO THEIR OWN HEALTH
DATA. WE NOW RESPOND TO MORE
THAN THIRTY MILLION API CALLS A
MONTH. SOURCE HI READERS- THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS NOW GOING TO
BECOME STANDARD AND REQUIRED
ALL PROVIDERS AND MOST PUBLIC
HEALTH PLANS BY RECENTLY
ENACTED FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
RAPIDLY ADVANCING WITH THE
STANDARD PROCEDURE HIV
POLLUTION. SO I GOAL HERE IS
REALLY IN DEMONSTRATE THE
CALIFORNIA PROVIDERS LEAD THE
NATION OPTION. AVAILABLE
STANDARDS BASED. HIV
METHODOLOGIES. THE COMMISSION
WALKING CHANGE IN DATA WORK
WITH HEALTH PLANS SB THREE
SEVENTY ONE OF DRAFTING WILL
REALLY PROVIDE ACCESS TO
FUNDING AND SUPPORT TO ALLOW
ALL PROVIDERS ACROSS KENTUCKY
ELAINE GET ASPIRIN FUNDS
BENEFIT. I WILL WELL I JUST
THINK DISAGREE OUT. FOR TO BE
SPEECH IDEA WHICH NEWS BATTLE
KNOWLEDGE THANK THANK YOU
THANKS VERY. THANK SO MUCH FOR
THE TEST. I NIBBLED MOVE ON
THIS TESTING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE THE FIRST TO
GO TO PUBLIC GALLERY. SAYING NO
WHEN THEY'RE AT THE PUBLIC
GALLERY MICROPHONE THAT'S MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SIGNAL IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVED
OUT TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
ONE AGAIN NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN IT'S. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A FEW PEOPLE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT THE TOP
WE GATHER THEIR LINE NUMBERS
THANK YOU. THE SEVENTH AND
AGAIN AS SOON AS YOU'RE ABLE TO.
THE END OF THE LINE FIFTY YOUR
MIKE AT THE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
JACKSON RAN FOR YOUR DENTAL. IN
COURT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE FIFTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARIA BARBOUR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE FORTY EIGHT
YEAR MIKE IS UP. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS FRED
NOPE WHERE REPRESENTING
STANFORD HEALTH CARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. WHY TWENTY ONE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN ST THE START WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE HEY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. LINE
TWENTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
SHARE WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THE CREATION OF THE
DIRECTION THE AWKWARD TAKING
AMBLE WORKING TOWARD THE FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE TWENTY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. RIGHT
SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE OCEAN IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME THANK YU
MODERATOR NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE
IS- NO LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND THAT'S BEEN
REGISTERED WITH US SO WILL THEN
GO ON TO THE PUBLIC GALLERY.
SAYING NO ONE AT THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE ON TO ONE
TWENTY FORTY SAYING NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE NOW TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE TO PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SEVENTY
ONE AGAIN NAME AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION ONLY. OR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO U. S. B. THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO COMMENT. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER LEYVA. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN I WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I THINK IT IS- IS SOMETHING
THAT IS REALLY WELL INTENTIONED
AND WOULD DO A LOT OF GOOD. I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT I DID
RECEIVE NOT OPPOSITION BUT SOME
CONCERNS FROM INLAND EMPIRE
HEALTH OF WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT. BUT I THINK THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO BE WORKING ON SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS AND I DO HAVE
ONE QUESTION. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE PREVIOUS
EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN TO ADVANCE I
E. EIGHTY. H. I. E. IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE FAILED TO THE
LACK OF REQUIREMENTS ON HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS TO PARTICIPATE.
STATES OF SIXTEEN SUCCESSFUL
HEALTH INFORMATION LAKE
MICHIGAN MARYLAND NORTH
CAROLINA ALL USE SOME FORM OF
STRONG LEVERAGE ON THE
PROVIDERS. AS AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE GOVERNOR IN HIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND I DON'T THINK THIS
BILL COVERS THAT- BUT DO YOU
THINK THERE'S A WAY TO ADDRESS
THAT. THE CENTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT QUESTION APPRECIATE
IT I BELIEVE THERE'S A WAY TO
DO IT PART OF THE CHALLENGES
THE RESOURCES. IF THERE ARE. NO
RESOURCES TO HELP THEM. COME
INTO COMPLIANCE THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO SET UP A STRUCTURE
RESET YOU GOTTA DO IT. AND
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT COST YOU
TO DO IT AND SO WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO THROUGH THIS IS TO
SET UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
HOW MUCH MONEY IT'S GOING TO
TAKE AND THEN WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO. MAKE IT HAPPEN SO
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS IS
A WORK IN PROSPEROUS. GET THE
SENATE HEALTHCARE. THANK YOU
SIR EGGMAN. THANK YOU MUCH S.
R. KOREA AND NOT. THAT I THINK
IS A GOOD BILL AND I THINK IT'S
GETTING OUT OF. VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AROUND. ASH ACCESS AND
EQUITY WHICH IS. A WHICH IS
WHAT WE HOW WE LEAD WITH OUR
VALUES. I AM. I TOOK MY- I AM.
ON CLOSING MY- I PUT MY LICENSE
BACK ON TRACK JUST SO I. HAD TO
TAKE SOME SEE. AND SO I THOUGHT
I SHOULD TAKE SOMETHING ON
TELEHEALTH- ANYWAY I GUESS I
JUST HAD NO IDEA OF THE
CONNECTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED ON
BOTH SIDES. OF BOTH THE
RECEIVER- AS WELL AS THE
PROVIDER. AND THE ALL POLL ALL
I THINK ALL OF WHAT YOU DON'T
SEE IN FRONT THAT GOES BEHIND
THE SCENES IN MAKING THAT
ENTIRE SYSTEM BE ABLE TO WORK.
SO THAT THE- THE CLIENT AND THE
PROVIDERS- ARE HAVE THE BEST
INFORMATION AND ARE ABLE TO-
INNER INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER
SO- I THINK IS A GOOD BILL AND
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR. ABSOLUTELY I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT THE
NEW BY CENTER EGGMAN AT THE
PERFECT TIME- CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR. A BRING FORWARD I DO WHICH
IS TO QUESTIONS TO THE AUTHOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN YES PLEASE. I'M
THE FIRST ONE IS THERE'S A
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED
LETTER FROM. ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION ABOUT SOME
PRIVACY ISSUES JUST READING
THAT LETTER. IT SEEMS LIKE.
SHE'S A PERHAPS COULD BE WORKED
THROUGH AND I'M JUST. WONDERING
TO THE AUTHOR YOU- RESPONSES IN
CONVERSATION. WITH EFF TO SEE
WHAT CAN BE WORKED OUT WE WILL
BE IN CONVERSATIONS THIS IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT THAT
CONVERSATION IT. UP BY THE
APPRECIATE THE ACCESS CAN BE
ANALYZED AND VIEWED IN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT WAYS IN EQUITY THE
SAME WAY SO YES. I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO DO THAT. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS HAS TO DO WITH-
DATA COLLECTION AROUND. A
DEMOGRAPHIC ISSUES ONE THING
THAT. HAS COME INTO FULL
SHINING LIGHT DURING COVE IT.
IS THAT WE DON'T- HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM- DOES NOT DO A GREAT JOB
COLLECTING DEMOGRAPHIC DATA.
WE'VE SEEN FOR EXAMPLE WITH
CODED. THE DATA THAT WE DO HAVE
WHICH IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH BUT AT
LEAST WE CAN SEE. SOME OF THE
AGE DISPARITIES AND RACIAL.
DISPARITIES AMONG COVE IT
IMPACT NOT JUST ONE. PARTICULAR
HEALTH PROBLEMS. AND SO WE'VE
NEVER DONE THE GREATEST JOB
AROUND- DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
COLLECTION AND THEN OF COURSE.
WITH SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY WE DO A CAN ONLY BE
DESCRIBED AS AN ABYSMAL JOB.
BASICALLY COLLECTING EITHER NO
DATA. OR EXCEPTIONALLY SPORADIC
AND LIMITED DATA ON IMPACTS.
WHETHER IT'S OF CODE OR
ANYTHING ELSE ON THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. AND EVEN LAST YEAR
WHEN WE PASS LEGISLATION
MANDATING THE COLLECTION. IT
REALLY HASN'T HAPPENED. IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY BECAUSE OF.
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF THE
DISJOINTED NATURE. OF THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SO ALL IT
TAKES IS ONE BOTTLE NEXT TO
PREVENT THAT. FROM HAPPENING.
SEMI I WOULD I WOULD I GUESS IS
A BE A REQUEST. I THINK THIS
BILL GIVEN ITS COOL WHICH IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT GOAL OF TO.
BOB THIS- IF BE AN AXE. A NEW
ARE. TO PERHAPS CORPORATE. IN
THE BILL. FOR DEVON. DATA
COLLECTION INCLUDE. SEXUAL AND
GENDER IDENTITY. ON AND TO SAYS
D. INTEGRATE THAT DATA
COLLECTION AND ASSISTANCE I
WANT TO REQUEST. ON THAT YOU
AND YOUR SPONSORS CONSIDER THAT
WE WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU WE HAVE A COALITION OF
GROUPS. THAT FOCUS ON AND I
THINK IT COULD BE A WIN WIN SO
IF YOU COULD MAYBE JUST COMMENT
ON- YES I DO I DO AGREE THAT-
THIS IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY TO GET THE INFORMATION. AT
THE EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY- NOT
AFTER WE'VE GOT A PANDEMIC
REACHING AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHO'S GETTING SICK
AND WHO ISN'T IT SEEMS TO ME
LIKE. THIS INFORMATION THIS
DATA- WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL
IN LOOKING AT- ILLNESSES AND
DISEASES AND UNDERSTANDING A
LITTLE BIT BETTER THEIR THEIR
ORIGIN SO HIGH. MORE I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE'LL CONNECT YOU WITH THE
GROUPS THAT ARE WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. OR QUESTIONS. K. IN
THE NO. UP YOU. IF NOT THE-
MAKES WILL TELL IS. ARE. FOR-
PRESIDING OFFICER ME NOTED- SO
SEE NINE OF US ARE KIND OF I
THOUGHT DON'T THINK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS BILL TO I WILL JUST
COMMENT THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT-
THERE'S A FROM THE- THAT ALSO
DRESSES SOMEBODY- PARALLEL
ISSUES INCLUDING ACTUALLY THE
REQUIREMENT HE SAID WHAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT ALSO IS IT
BECOMES A RESOURCE DISCUSSION
TO. APPRECIATE THAT YOUR THAT
THE ONGOING WORKS TO FURTHER
REFINE THE BILL- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE- SO SENATE LEADERS COURSE
MENTIONED- BISMOL- PROFITABLE.
THE DISMAL. OF TRYING TO THE OF
COLLECTING DATA ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IDENTITY AND
OF COURSE FOR THE API COMMUNITY
IT'S- THERE'S ALSO
DISAGGREGATION OF THE DATA AND
SUBGROUPS BECAUSE TOO OFTEN-
THINGS GET MASS THAT WAY AS
WELL SO. APPRECIATE YOU ALSO
LOOKING INTO THOSE ISSUES AS
WELL- BUT THAT CERTAINLY. WANT
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I THINK- ALL THE SENATORS THAT-
HAVE QUESTIONS IN THAT HAVE
SOME REALLY REALLY GOOD IDEAS.
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU
SACRAMENTO THE TO THIS BILL IS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
EGGMAN THE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
FIRST WOULD BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAN KAN HI MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I EGGMAN. AYE EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ A
GROVE. HER TADO. THEY ALL.
LEYVA AYE LIMA. SENATOR NAME
ONLY SB THREE TO I LIMON ROTH
ROTH AYE RUBIO. WIENER HI
WIENER I. EIGHT OKAY THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL
HOLD THE BILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO
NEXT UP- ACTUALLY CENTER EGGMAN
WE CAN IF YOU WISH OF WITH
PRIDE STAFF PEOPLE TESTIFY AT
THE DESK AND LESS YOU WANT TO-
IF LESS MIXING. AROUND SO THANK
YOU US SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB THREE
EIGHTY I DO UNDERSTAND THERE'S
A BIT OF A THERE MAY BE A BIT
OF PUBLIC INTEREST SO I'M JUST
GONNA NOUNS AHEAD OF TIME IN
ADDITION TO OF COURSE PROVIDING
THE TIME THAT ANNOUNCES THE
VERY BEGINNING FOR- FOR THE
TESTIMONY AND COMMENTS I AM
HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
GET THROUGH ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT I AM GOING TO PUT A
CAP OF TWENTY MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE. NOT THAT WE HAVE TO GO
THAT LONG- BUT- IT'S IF THERE
IS THAT MUCH INTEREST AND I
WOULD POINT OUT FOR ANYONE TO
UNFORTUNATELY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO- TO GET IN BEFORE WE
GET THAT TIME LIMIT THAT YOU
CAN CERTAINLY SEE PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE- THROUGH OUR WEBSITE
SO WITH THAT. CENTER AND WHEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR- I
WAS MOVES IT FEELS AWKWARD AT
TO SPEAK. WITHOUT MY BACK TO
EVERYBODY- BUT IT'S- IT IS A IS
ANOTHER. ANOTHER ISSUE THE
PANDEMIC I GUESS THAT WORLD
DEALING WITH- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE THE CHAIR IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR EVERYBODY'S
WORK ON THIS AND- TO SAY I
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB THREE EIGHTY WHICH
WILL MAKE SOME REVISIONS TO THE
END OF LIFE OPTION ACT.
CURRENTLY I UP BY ORIGINALLY
AUTHORED THE BILL IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND IT WENT INTO EFFECT
JUNE OF TWENTY SIXTEEN. SO THE
INITIAL BUILD. WE'VE HELD
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ACT WITH INPUT FROM.
CALIFORNIA PARTNER PUBLIC
HEALTH PROVIDERS HOSPITALS
PATIENTS FAMILIES AND MORE-
THERE ARE. REPORTS THAT COME
OUT EVERY SINGLE YEAR ABOUT I.
THROUGH THOSE THOSE HEARINGS
AND ADDITIONAL DATA AND
ANECDOTES WE'VE HEARD SOME OF
THE BARRIERS TO ACCESS FOR
PATIENTS. OVER FIVE YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION THE CURRENT
PROCESS TO OBTAIN MEDICAL AID
IN DYING. DRUGS IS
UNNECESSARILY CUMBERSOME AND IS
CREATED MANY ROADBLOCKS FOR
MANY DYING PATIENTS. ONE STUDY
FROM KAISER PERMANENTE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SHOW THAT
ONE THIRD. OF TERMINALLY ILL
ADULTS TO REQUEST THE USE OF
THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT DIED
BEFORE COMPLETING THE TIME
CONSUMING PROCESS WHICH
INCLUDES A FIFTEEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD. BETWEEN ORAL REQUESTS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN OREGON
UPDATED THEIR LAW AND
AUTHORIZED A WAIVER OF THE
FIFTEEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
BETWEEN OUR REQUEST TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. RECENT DATA SHOWS A
20% INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
PATIENTS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE DIED DURING THE WAITING
PERIOD. WERE ABLE TO ACCESS
THEIR MEDICAL AID IN DYING
THANKS TO THE AMENDMENTS. TO
ADDRESS SIMILAR CONCERN JUST
LAST WEEK NEW MEXICO CHANGE
THEIR FIFTEEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD BETWEEN TWO OR REQUEST
TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS. WHY WOULD
WE LIKE TO PREVENT ANY MORE
TERMINALLY ILL TELL KATC TERMLY
ILL CALIFORNIANS FROM SUFFERING
UNNECESSARILY. IS ALSO BECOME
CLEAR THAT THE SECOND WRITTEN
REQUEST. DESCRIBED AS A FINAL
ATTESTATION IS UNNECESSARY IT
IS GIVEN TO THE PATIENT BY
THEIR ATTENDING PHYSICIAN WITH
INSTRUCTIONS TO FILL OUT. THE
PRESCRIBED FORM WITHIN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OF SELF
ADMINISTERING THE AID IN DYING
DRUGS. TERMLY ILL PATIENTS WHO
ARE NEARING THEIR DEATHS HAVE
ALREADY. HAD TWO EVALUATIONS
PLACED INTO OR REQUEST THE
FIRST WRITTEN REQUEST THAT WAS
WITNESSED BY TWO INDIVIDUALS.
THIS FOURTH REQUEST SEEMS
REDUNDANT AND- AND PATIENTS
REPORT. THE ADVANTAGE REPORT I
CAN JUST ONE MORE THING THAT
THEY HAVE TO TRY TO CHECK OFF
THE BOX AT THE VERY END.
CERTAINLY THE END OF THE LUCK
LIFE OPTION ACT. REQUIRES THE
ATTENDING PHYSICIAN TO REMIND.
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS TO NOT
SELF ADMINISTER AID IN DYING
DRUGS IN A PUBLIC PLACE THIS IS
BECAUSE SOME CONFUSION AMONG
SOME HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THAT
INTERPRET THAT LAW TO PROHIBIT
PATIENTS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
MEDICAL AID IN DYING IN THEIR
FACILITY. ANOTHER BARRIER IS
THE INCONSISTENCY IN WHICH OUR
REQUEST FOR AID IN DYING DRUGS
ARE DATED AND DOCUMENTED IN
PATIENTS RECORDS. THIS BILL
MAINTAINS THE COR ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ONLY TERMINALLY
ILL ADULTS WITH A TERMINAL
DIAGNOSIS AND SIX MONTHS OR
LESS TO LIVE FOR MENTALLY
CAPABLE OF MAKING THEIR OWN
HEALTH CARE DECISIONS AND ARE
ABLE TO SELF IN JUST. EIGHT IN
DYING MEDICATIONS QUALIFY UNDER
THE LAW. ATIONS WILL STILL HAVE
TO MAKE TWO ORAL REQUESTS AS A
WRITTEN REQUEST. IN THE
EVALUATED BY TWO SEPARATE
POSITIONS IF EITHER PHYSICIAN
FEELS THAT IS NECESSARY. THE
PATIENT MAY ALSO BE EVALUATED
BY A LICENSED PSYCHIATRIST OR
PSYCHOLOGIST TO CERTIFY. THAT
THE PATIENT IS MEDICALLY
CAPABLE MENTALLY CAPABLE OF
GIVING INFORMED CONSENT. THIS
BILL REQUIRE THAT THE DATE OF
THE ORAL AND WRITTEN REQUEST
MUST BE DOCUMENTED ENSURING
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS. ACCESS
TO TIMELY MEDICAL CARE UPON A
TRANSFER OF CARE THAT MEDICAL
RECORD WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL. WILL ALSO
SHORTEN THE MANDATORY WAITING
PERIOD BETWEEN OR REQUEST FROM
FIFTEEN. DAYS TO FORTY EIGHT
HOURS. THIS BILL WILL DEFINE
PUBLIC PLACE AND CLARIFY THAT A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY DOES NOT
FALL UNDER THAT DEFINITION. IF
THE PROVIDER IS UNWILLING OR
UNABLE TO HONOR A PATIENT'S
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION ABOUT
THE POLICY. AND TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A STANDARD OF CARE
BEING UPHELD BETWEEN THE
PHYSICIAN AND THE PATIENT. THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE THEM TO
INFORM THE PATIENT THAT THEY DO
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE ACT.
DOCUMENT THE PATIENT'S DATE OF
REQUEST. AND PROVIDER NOTICE TO
THE PATIENT OF THEIR OBJECTION
IN THE MEDICAL RECORD. TRANSFER
THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL RECORD
IMMEDIATELY UPON REQUEST. THIS
BILL THIS BILL WILL ALSO REPEAL
THE SUNSET DATE. DATE WE KNOW
FROM DATA COLLECTED FROM THE
CALIFORNIADEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND TERMINALLY
ILL INDIVIDUALS HAVE RECEIVED A
PRESCRIPTION FOR AID IN DYING
DRUGS. THAT'S TWO THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL STORE GRANTED THE
OPPORTUNITY BE IN CHARGE. OF
THEIR END OF LIFE CARE. THE
PROTECTIONS BUILT INTO THE LAW
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE THERE HAVE
BEEN NO REPORTED INSTANCES OF
ABUSE- CORE OR CORROSION. AND
IT'S TIME TO MAKE THIS LAW
PERMANENT ENSURE THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE TERMINALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE THE RIGHT
TO REMAIN ANONYMOUS. AND DIE
WITH DIGNITY. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN AND JUST- I WASN'T SURE
IF I MISSED IT- AND SO THAT
YOUR CUSTOMERS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH IT BUT YOU ARE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS. THAT IS
CORRECT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN. WELL WE'RE LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SO. I HAVE HERE WE HAVE
FIVE DOCTOR RYAN SPIELVOGEL-
AND- BUNNY MUSKEGON IS THE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- AND I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TEMPORALLY.
CALLUNA FOR QUESTIONS SO-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON
DOCTOR SPIELVOGEL AND BONNIE
MCKEE AGAIN. I WILL CHOOSE- TWO
MINUTES APIECE TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES OF SOMEONE RUNS OVER IT
TAKES AWAY TIME FROM THE SECOND
PERSON- SO- YOU CAN BRING THEM
ON THE LINE AND THEN THAT. TAX
BILL WILL GO AT LEAST IF YOU'RE
GOING FIRST- PLEASE BEGIN. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN AND
DOCTOR PAN AND ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MY NAME IS DR RYAN SPIELVOGEL
ON A FAMILY DOCTOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SUTTER HEALTH I'M
HERE TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE EIGHTY. I PERSONALLY
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIANS LIKE
TOPCONNECTED MEDICAL AID IN
DYING IN CALIFORNIA FOR MY
PATIENTS. BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
POWERFUL TOOL FOR THEM AT THE
END OF THEIR LIVES. TO BE ABLE
TO GET SOME OF THE POWER BACK
THAT THEY- VERY FREQUENTLY LOSE
DURING THEIR TIME PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY PATIENTS DO
NOT ACCOUNT FOR OBSTACLES WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO ACCESS AID IN
DYING. I WANT TO SECOND BUT
SENATOR EGGMAN VERY WONDERFULLY
PUT- THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLE IS THE MANDATORY
MINIMUM. FIFTEEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD BETWEEN THE TWO ORAL
REQUESTS. FOR AID IN DYING
MEDICATION REQUIRED UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW. A LOT OF
MEDICATIONS I YOU MAKE THEIR
REQUEST. WOULD SUFFICIENT LEAD
TIME BUT CAN IN THE BEGINNING
BOB DOWN IN THE RIVER FOR OR
THAT THERE IS AN TO FORM
REFERRAL. THAT THEY'RE IN. AND
BY THE TIME THEY GET TO ME IT
IT TO LATE FOR THEM TO ACT TAKE
PART- ANSWER THERE HAVE
BEEN START INTO TO SEE HOW.
OFTEN PATIENTS DYING DURING THE
WAITING PERIOD- I BELIEVE SHE
CITED HI. DATA DATA THAT ABOUT
A THIRD DIED DURING THE WAITING
PERIOD AND AN AUDIT OF A SUBSET
OF. PATIENTS OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SHOWED SIMILAR NUMBERS
AROUND 25% WHO. DIED DURING THE
MINIMUM WAITING. THESE PATIENTS
HAVE RECEIVED EVEN DYING HAD TO
PRESCRIBE PHYSICIAN BEEN A TO
EITHER WAY THE WAY PERIOD OR AT
THE SUGGESTION. THE WAITING.
FOR MEDICALLY. I AND I REVIEW
FAR TOO MANY CHOI OF PATIENTS
WHO. OF THE- MONTHS EARLIER BUT
THAT WERE IN THE TAKE A
ANYTHING AFTER THAT UNTIL LATE
TOO LATE IN THE NIGHT. TOO MANY.
OKAY IN THIS IS A POWER TOOL
OTHERS JEFF FOR THIS PATIENT
POPULATION- WHEN THEY OTHERWISE
HAVE VERY LITTLE CAN AND I
THINK YOU YOUR TIME THEY
WELCOME ANY YOU YOU ON HAVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU A
BY MIKE AND- THANK YOU. MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR A LONG WEEK TESTIFIED TODAY
MY NAME IS BONNIE AGAIN AND I'M
A LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER FROM GRASS VALLEY. I
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY.
MY MOM DIED OF BREAST CANCER
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
CHAPTER THE WHOLE REPORT WAIT
TO DIE. SOMETIMES EVEN THE BEST
POSSIBLE CARE CANNOT MANAGE A
DYING PERSON SUFFERING
ADEQUATELY. OUTLOOK MY MOTHER'S
EXPERIENCE. I'M FIFTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE OF HER CHOOSING.
SHE IS AID IN AND HER-
UNBEARABLE. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
THROUGHOUT HER BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA END OF LIFE OPTION
MY MOM SIDE PEOPLE IN HER SLEEP
HELD BY MY FATHER AND I. RATHER
THAN IN THE AGONY SHE FEARED.
SADLY SHAKESPEAREAN ACTOR LATER
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS TO ACCESS THE
LAW. THE FIRST DOCTOR SHOT HER
ONCOLOGIST CHOSE NOT TO BE
HEARD DR FOR MEDICAL EIGHTY
NINE BUT DID REFER HER TO A
HOSPITAL AND ANOTHER POSITION
WHO WOULD SUPPORT HER. THEY ALL
FOUGHT BACK REQUEST. HER NEW
DOG IN. I WAS THE FIRST FOUR
WEEKS. AND MADE HER START THE
WAY PERIOD. THAT MAY SHE HAD TO
WAIT YEAH ANOTHER DAY WHEN SHE
WAS RAPIDLY. THIS WAS
TRAUMATIZED FOR MY- WHEN ASKED
THE FIRST TIME SHE HAD A MADE
UP HER MIND SHE WANTED OPTION
AND SHE WAS ALREADY. SHE
WORRIED THE WHOLE KIND OF THE
KEY PROGRESSION WOULD DO SO
FORM SO SHE WOULDN'T BE A TO
MAKE IT TO THE OUT YET AGAIN
AND SHE DIED. DURING THE
WAITING. SHE WANTED TO DIE
PEOPLE NOT IN THE AGONY SHE WAS
ALREADY EXPERIENCING. IF YOU'RE
NOT ADDRESS EITHER THE PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU PUT YEAH SB THE
OTHER THANK YOU ARE L. TO IT'S
IN THE TOP OF THE BOX BOB.
THANK SO MUCH FOR YOUR TEST.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE EIGHTY ITS NAME-
AFFILIATION ORGANIZATION ONLY-
WELL FIRST BEGAN IN THE PUBLIC
GALLERY TO SEE WITNESS THERE.
COME THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR INTO MANY AT EMILY THAT.
MEDICAL WE JUST WANT TO THINK
THE AUTHOR SPONSORS AND
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK AND
WAS OUR SUPPORT OF THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. SEEN OTHER WITNESSES UP IN
THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S NOW
MOVE INTO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAY NO WITNESSES ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR- PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THREE EIGHTY AND AGAIN IT'S
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE. AND
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. A LINE OF FORTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE SIXTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROCKSTAND
GOL REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. WHY LIFE FOURTEEN YEAR MY
COULD OPEN. SH MY NAME IS KAREN
HERE I'VE BEEN A REGISTERED
NURSE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AS
SURVIVOR OF STAGE FOUR BREAST
CANCER WITH THIRTY NINE I
SUPPORT. SB THREE EIGHTY
PROFESSIONALLY AND PERSONALLY
WITH ALL OF THE TOOLS TO STATE
MEDIA PERMANENT LAW. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT LINE PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN MARIN I'M
AN IRAN AND CONCHOLOGY IN
HOUSES ARE RAN- REPRESENTING LA
PATIENT. AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THREE EIGHTY AND IT'S
IMPROVEMENTS THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH NEXT LINE PLEASE.
LINE SEVENTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THIS IS DOCTOR
ROBERT OLVERA I'M A RETIRED
FAMILY PHYSICIAN FROM
MEMORIALCARE HEALTH SYSTEM OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
BLIGHTED SEVENTY THREE OR MY
COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS DICK
BECAUSE- AND I AM VERY STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU THAT'S FINE. BLIND
SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS PATRICK
MCMILLAN I AM A PALLIATIVE
MEDICINE PHYSICIAN- HERE IN
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
THE LINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS SUSAN
KIANA FROM THE HOSPITAL AND END
UP LIKE THAT IN THE CENTER
COAST OF CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. LINE SIXTY HERE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATHY CONWAY AND THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF HOSPICE OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND- OUR
ORGANIZATION AND I PERSONALLY
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU EXLINE. A LINE
SIXTY SIX HERE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO
THE CROWD AND THE DAUGHTER OF A
LONG TIME YOU SEE HER PLEASE
PERFECT YOUR ACCESS BUT DID NOT
ALL COMMIT LEGALIZED MEDICAL
AID IN DYING IN THE EMPHATIC
SUPPORT OF THAT B. THREE. THANK
YOU EXLINE. LEVINE SEVENTY NINE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. LINE SEVENTY
NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MAIL. LINE%
SEVENTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN
KIAS I AM BRITNEY MINARD
HUSBAND AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. THE LINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO I AM RABBI DAN SINGER I'M
THE RABBI OF TEMPLE BETH EL IN
RIVERSIDE AND I AM VERY
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE LINE
FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MAIL YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. BLIND SEVENTY YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS DORIS I
TELL I'M IN OUR AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER FOR OVER SIXTY EIGHT
YEARS AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIX SO. RIGHT THANK YOU
AT THE THIRD AS THREE EIGHTY
SO- NEXT I DON'T. THREE EIGHTY.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
LINE. ALIVE EIGHTY NINE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. WINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME
IS MARSHALL GOLDMAN I AM A
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER WITHIN A
HEALTH OF SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA I HAD BEEN AT THESE
UTILIZATION THANK AIM
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION PLEASE
OPEN. THANK THANK YOU ASSUME
YOUR SABBATICAL SOCIAL WORKER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT LINE PLEASE. LINE
NINETY YOU'RE MY COULD NOT. MY
NAME IS LISA HIGH COMPLIMENT
AND THE HARD WORK FOR KAISER
PERMANENTE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY I HAVE THANK YOU WORKED
CLOSELY WITH VACATIONS TO
RESCUE THAT COULD YOU EXPLAIN
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THAT THE
PATENT THANK YOU LET'S MOVE NOW
ONTO THE OPPOSITION- WE HAVE-
TWO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SO PLEASE BRING ON.
JERRY GOLDEN- WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION
DEFENSE FUND AND DR BRIAN
PALLISTER FROM THE RIVER
UNIVERSITY NEVADA RENO. IF YOU
CAN BRING THEM ON THE LINE
PLEASE. AND YOU EACH THEIR
ICONS ARE OPEN OKAY SO YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL FORM IS
FOR BOTH OF YOU SO I SAID OF
FIRST PERSON RUNS OVER AND THAT
TAKES THAT FOUR MINUTES SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH A MARYLAND
GOLDEN. PLEASE BEGIN. HI I'M
MARILYN GOLDEN WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION AND
DEFENSE FUND CAN I BE HEARD.
YES PLEASE AGAIN HELLO. RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHEN THE
SMALLEST PACKAGE SUPPORTERS
APPOINTED TO THESE PROVISIONS
AND SAFEGUARDS. TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS ARE PROTECTED. NOW
PROPONENTS WANT TO STRIP THEM
AWAY- I'M REALLY IS OF THE
PERIOD A LANCER STUDY FOUND.
THAT PATIENTS WILL TO LIVE
COSTRUCTION WAIT 30% IN A
TWELVE HOUR PERIOD AND THE
LONGER IT WENT THE HIGHER THE
PERCENTAGE OF FLUCTUATION SO
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT YOU KNOW A
BAD DAY OR TWO THAT DAY SHOULD
NOT MEAN A DEATH SENTENCE A FEW
HOURS LATER- I ALSO WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE SUNSET CLAUSE.
ACTIVE CAL LET. WOULD LOOK AT
EXTENSION DATA EXTENSION DATA
BEFORE MAKING A RASH DECISION
TO ELIMINATE THE SUNSET CLAUSE
BUT LET'S LOOK AT THE SORRY
STATE OF CALIFORNIANS DATA
REPORTING. THERE IS NO DATA
ABOUT WHAT PATIENTS ILLNESSES
EVEN WORK UNLIKE IN OTHER
STATES WHERE IT IS LEGAL.
THERE'S NO STATISTICS ABOUT
REFERRALS FOR PSYCHOLOGICAL
EVALUATIONS UNLIKE IN OTHER
STATES THERE ARE NO REASONS FOR
PATIENTS AFTER CLASS UNLIKE IN
OTHER STATES. THERE'S NO DATA
ABOUT WHEN THE PATIENT INGESTED
LEGAL DRUGS OR WHETHER THEY HAD
COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS
REGURGITATION OR SEIZURES OR
WAKING UP INSTEAD OF DYING. ALL
OF WHICH HAVE BEEN REPORTED-
AND- IT WOULD HAVE COME TO
LIGHT IN OTHER STATES. NO ONE'S
REQUIRED TO BE PRESENT AT THE
TIME OF INGESTION SO THERE'S NO
WAY TO REALLY KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED AND MOST EGREGIOUS
CALIFORNIA HAS ACKNOWLEDGED
DESTRUCTION OF THE LAND
UNDERLYING DATA EVERY THREE
YEARS. WHAT THE OVERSIGHT
HEARING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WHO DEAL WITH THE
DATA THE STATE DOES COLLECTIONS
LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW. BUT THEY HAVE NO
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. I CAN REMOVE
THE SUNSET CLAUSE WHILE
IGNORING MANY CRUCIAL THING
THANK. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR SITE WITNESS-
DOCTOR TELLS. YEAH THIS IS
DOCTOR BY CALL ON MCCALLUM NAY
AND CALIFORNIA SISTERS WHO ALSO
SEE AS THE GOVERNOR THE BOTTOM
FOR THE MAYOR COLLEGE TO SAY
HOW TO BRING WHAT I CONSIDER
THE PER THANK YOU COM OF THIS
BILL THIS BILL STATES IN A
POSITION LIKE MYSELF DOES NOT
CONSIDER ASSISTED SUICIDE OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT AND I DON'T
INFORM THE PATIENT AS SUCH BUT
I HAVE NOT PROVIDED INFORMED
CONSENT WHICH INFERS LIABILITY
IN NEGLIGENCE WHAT IS FIRST
REMEMBER THAT ASSISTED SUICIDE
IS NOT UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED AS
A STANDARD OF MEDICAL CARE FOR
TERMINAL ILLNESS. IT'S SUPPOSED
IS UNETHICAL BY THE TWO LARGEST
PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATIONS STATE
MERITED MEDICAL SAYS YOU
SHOULDN'T AND THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF PHYSICIANS THIS BILL
ALSO STATES THAT PHYSICIANS
MUST REFER THE PATIENT FOR
SOMEONE ELSE WHO'S WILLING TO
GIVE THEM THE LEGAL MEDICATIONS
EVEN IF THE REFERRING PHYSICIAN
CONSIDERS THIS PRACTICE NOT
ONLY UNETHICAL BUT NOT THE
STANDARD OF CARE FOR PARTICULAR
ILLNESS AND WHAT OF SOMEONE
LIKE MYSELF DOESN'T THINK THE
PATIENT IS TERMINAL WITHIN A
FIFTEEN DAY FOR SIX MONTHS FOR
A FORTY EIGHT HOUR WINDOW. IF I
HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT OR NOT
AND A GUY DOWN THE ROAD
BELIEVES THEY ARE THAT OPENS ME
UP TO LIABILITY CENSURE AND
SANCTIONS SO THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION IS WHY ARE WE TRYING
TO BUILD BERKELEY OVERDOSE
PATIENTS WHEN WE'RE NOT EVEN
SURE ABOUT HOW MUCH TIME THEY
HAVE WELL. SPELL DIRECTLY
CONTRADICTS FEDERAL LAW I
BELIEVE THAT SECTION FIFTEEN
FIFTY THREE OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT WHICH PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION. DISSIPATION AND
ASSIST SILVA. AND FINALLY WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THESE OX YOU'RE
ASKING LIKE ME TO. MENTAL TO IT.
NOT EVEN THE SIZE OR LICENSE
LIKE SOMEONE THAT HAS FULLER
TRY THAN MY- SO ASK WINDOWS A
PRESCRIPTION PICK YEARS. TAKE
THE TO DIE. AND MAKE IT TO DIE
FOR THE LICENSE REVOKED UNITY
IS ALREADY OUT TROUBLE ACTS TO
CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH FROM TO.
THANK YOU YOU THANK YOU DR
ALASTAIR BUT THAT WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESS IN- TO. A THREE
EIGHTY WILL BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY HERE AND CHAMBER
C. KNOWN AT THE MICROPHONE
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ST ON ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE- OPEN THE
LINES TO PEOPLE WISHING TO
TESTIFY AGAINST IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE EIGHTY. AND SINCE
YOU SIGNED. THE LINES PLEASE I
HAVE THE BEGIN. I GET ITS NAME
TO MR TO AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON. THANK YOU. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE.
ZERO IN LIGHT OF FORTY FOUR
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. SHORT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE OF
CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR MY GET UP
AND. GREG BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR MY GET UP AND-
THIS IS MERI LEE SCHNEIDER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RIGHT TO
LIFE OF KERN COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU EXLINE.
LINE FORTY- MY GET UP AND- HERE
IN MEMBERS BARBARA PLATE WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU EXLINE. WELL I AM
THIRTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TIMES CARS ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT POLITICAL
GROUP ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT
THE CHURCH OF JESUS CHRIST OF
LATTER DAY SAINTS IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU EXLINE. LINE TWENTY YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. THANK YOU HIS
BRIAN JOHNSTON REPRESENTING
SENIORS AGAINST SUICIDE AND WE
URGE YOU STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE SIXTY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. TONY
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ALLY AT YOUR
MICROSCOPIC. BUT AN ULTRA STATE
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER
CALIFORNIA LUWAK IN STRONG
OPPOSITION WITH THE SUPPORT OF
A GOVERNING NATIONALLY LACK
RESOLUTION CHAMPIONING HEALTH
CARE STOP TRYING TO KILL THAT
ANYTHING THANK THANK YOU.
THANKS LINE. ALIVE THIRTY FOUR
YEAR MIKE AT THE OPEN. TONY
ROSE ALL INPUT CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANKS LINE. ONE THIRTY ONE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN EMBERS THIS IS ROBERT
NAYLOR REPRESENTING FEELS TO
THAN COMPANY OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE SIXTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY KIDS UP. I AM A
SEVEN ON THE FLOODING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE FIFTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HENRY
WALTER ANESTHESIOLOGISTS IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE. IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT OKAY THANK YOU-
NOW LET'S BRING THIS BACK TO A
MEMBERS ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THAT'S OKAY CENTER
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE OTHER QUESTION IF I MAY
THROUGH THE CHURCH YES PLEASE
THANK YOU. OKAY WALK ME THROUGH
THIS- YOU HAVE A PATIENT WHO
HAS- CANCER YOUR THE PHYSICIAN
LET'S SAY IT'S BEING OKAY
YOU'RE THE DOCTOR AND THE
PATIENT CAN YOU TELL ME DO YOU
HAVE CANCER WHICH I'M ASSUMING
WE WOULD KNOW BEFORE FIFTEEN
DAYS BEFORE MY DEATH BED AND
THAT I'VE BEEN RECEIVING
TREATMENT BUT YOU SAY I THINK
YOU'VE GOT ABOUT FIFTEEN DAYS.
AND THEN I SAY OKAY WHY WOULD
LIKE TO EXERCISE MY END OF LIFE
OPTIONS YOU SAY FINE- BUT YOU
HAVE TO WAIT TWO DAYS. IS THAT
RIGHT. PHONE. DO YOU HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS ON THAT BECAUSE I DO
SO THAT WHEN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS AND I
KEEP GOING THROUGH THE ANALYSIS
OF WHAT THE MEMBERS WANT TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
I'M VERY TORN ON THIS ISSUE BUT
I DO WANT AT LEAST NOW YOU KNOW
MAKE AN EDUCATED VOTE HERE AS
TO HOW THE TIME WHEN YOU CHANGE
THE NOTE WENT IN TWO WEEKS IT'S
DOWN FORTY EIGHT DAYS- HOURS.
I'M SORRY HOURS GOSH NINE DAYS-
SO THAT THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING
IS IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE ME
LIKE A BASIC HERE'S ON THIS
WOULD ROLL OUT CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION- SO I
THINK THAT THE ONE THING THAT
WE NEED TO SAY IS THAT SOMEONE
IS NOT GIVEN A DIAGNOSIS AND
REQUESTING A MEDICATION I DON'T
THINK EVER HAPPENS LIKE THAT
RIGHT SOMEBODY HAS BEEN GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS THEY HAVE GENERALLY
YOU KNOW SOME THE OPPOSITION I
GREW. IT CAN IS ARE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE A TO. ILLNESS THEY ARE
GOING TO DIE. THE OFTENTIMES IN
IN FOR ALL THE DATA WE'VE SEEN
PEOPLE ENGAGE ACTIVELY IN
TREATMENT AND IN TRIALS AND
THEN CHEMO AND DO EVERYTHING.
TILL THEY DECIDED THAT'S- THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE NOT. WORTH T
ANYMORE AND WE'RE TO END IN THE
END IS VERY NEAR IT IT IS NOT
IT THE END OF THE MIRACLE HAS
NOT HAPPENED THE TREATMENT HAS
NOT TURNED THINGS AROUND. AT
THAT POINT SOMEBODY OFTENTIMES
THAT TOWARDS THE END THEY HAVE
NOW. DETERIORATED TO A POINT
WHERE IF THEY WERE TO ASK THE
PHYSICIAN. I'D LIKE TO EXERCISE
THIS- THE PHYSICIAN AT THAT
POINT AND I THINK WHAT WE HEARD
SOME SOMETIMES IF YOU HAVEN'T
ASKED YOU DON'T KNOW RIGHT SO
THAT POSITIONAL SAY OKAY YOU'LL
HAVE FIFTY DAYS I'M NOT GOING
TO DO IT AND YOU SAY CAN I GET
A REFER. A I'M SORRY I'M A
DOCUMENT WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
SAYING YOU HAVE TO DOCUMENT
THAT YOU ARE NOT GOING TO DO IT
AND THEN- SO THEN THAT THAT
PATIENT HAS TO GO. WITH HOPE
YOU KNOW MAYBE A VERY SHORT
TIME TO TRY TO FIND ANOTHER
POSITION TO DO THAT INITIAL AND
THEN WAIT FIFTEEN DAYS AFTER
THAT TIME. TO ASK THE SECOND
POSITION IT IS IT IS THAT IT IS
IT IS THAT PERIOD SOMETIMES AND
LIKE WE HEARD ONE OF THE YOUNG
WOMEN SUPPORTERS CALLED IN AND
SAID. IT THEY HAD THOUGHT
PHYSICIAN WAS GOING SAY OKAY-AND THEY- WHEN THEY WERE TOLD
NO THAT THAT STARTED THE CLOCK
BUT THAT DIDN'T START THE CLOCK
BECAUSE- THEY WERE NOT
EVALUATED. TO THAT DEGREE. SO
THAT'S THE ISSUE AND WE'RE NOT
ANTICIPATING THAT PEOPLE WILL.
ACTIVATE THAT FORTY EIGHT HOURS
IT IS MORE OF A SAFEGUARD. FROM
THE ALL THE PEOPLE WE HEARD
THAT SAID IT WASN'T TOO LATE
AND THEN HE OR SHE DIED IN
EXACTLY THE WAY THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO DIE. AFTER HAVING TOLD
EVERYBODY THIS IS YOU KNOW NOT
WHAT I WANT. AND ENDING UP SO
THAT. THAT IS WHAT'S BEEN FOUND
CONSISTENTLY IN OTHER STATES
AND THAT'S WHY- WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT SAME THING. IF IT IF IT
LEAVES COMMITTEE. OKAY THAT
DOES HELP ME THANK YOU IN
UNDERSTANDING THE TIMELINE- I
KNOW. I WILL BE HONEST WITH
YOU- YOU KNOW I LISTEN TO BOTH
SIDES OF THIS AND I WAS HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY WHEN YOU KNOW YOUR
FIRST BILL CAME DURING
STRUGGLED. MIGHTILY WITH THAT
FRANKLY AS A AS A CATHOLIC- BUT
IS ALSO SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO. YOU
KNOW STEP INTO MY LIFE TO THE
TO THE EXTREMES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE SO THIS IS.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE BY- THE
TIME LINE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
CONCERN I GET WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AT SOME OF THESE PATIENTS HAVE
FOUND THEMSELVES IN WORDS VERY
FRUSTRATING OF A VERY MADE THE
DECISION AND THEN YET THEY
CAN'T FOLLOW THROUGH ON THAT
DECISION I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT. THOUGH I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERNS OF SOME OTHERS
WHERE- THAT IS A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. DURING WHICH-
YEAH I HAVE SOME BAD DAYS I
REMEMBER GOING THROUGH THIS
WITH MY OWN FATHER LIVES SOME
DAYS ARE GREAT SOME DAYS ARE
NOT SO GREAT AND- HIS MOOD
CHANGED WITH THAT. SO THAT IS
OF CONCERN BUT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU- BRING A BILL
FORWARD AND NINE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO.
HELP EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO THANK YOU. THANK
UP OKAY TO THAT. NUMBER
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT ALSO THAT
THAT THAT PEOPLE DIED BUT THEN
THIS LIKE SOMEBODY WITH A LESS
THAN CAN NO LONGER LIFT IT UP
TO BE ABLE TO SELF ADMINISTER
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE
CRITERIA AS WELL YOU MUST BE
ABLE TO. SELF ADMINISTER. AND
THE AGONY OF WARNING IT AND IT
BEING THERE AND THEN. JUST
WATCHING IT. AND I WILL SAY THE
DATA ALSO. CLEARLY SHOWS THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO GET THE
PRESCRIPTION DON'T TAKE IT BUT
IT'S JUST THE COMFORT. THAT
THEY'RE- THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
RELAX THEN AND YOU KNOW AND
DIED A NATURAL DEATH ON THEIR
OWN TERMS STILL. BUT KNOWING
THAT THAT THAT IS THERE IN CASE
THEY NEED. THANK YOU A CERTAIN
AMOUNT. THANK YOU AS THE STATE
AND SENATOR I WAS NOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
BUT CERTAINLY I HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THIS BILL AND THEN YOU
KNOW IT CAUSED A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS IN THE DISTRICT-
ONE QUESTION FOR YOU IN THAT
ECONOMY AND THE MY QUESTION IS
THE OPPOSITION SPOKE ABOUT DATA
HOWEVER AND THE LACK THERE OF
THE DATA THAT'S COLLECTED
HOWEVER YOU REFERENCE DATA
COLLECTED IN BOTH YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT AND IN THIS LAST-RESPONSE TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
LAKE ELSINORE. HE KNEW THAT IT
KIND OF JUST COMMENTED OR HELP
US UNDERSTAND- WHETHER OR NOT
WE COLLECT DATA WHAT DATA IS
APPROPRIATE AND HOW THAT DATA
IS INFORMING- THE DIRECTION YOU
ARE TAKING- IN THIS NEXT KIND
OF PHASE OF THIS BILL MMHM
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION YEAH
SO WE LOOK AT THE DATA FROM
OTHER STATES AS WELL SO THE
STATE OF OREGON HAS HAD. THE
ACT IN PLACE FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS NOW SO WE LOOK AT THE
DATA AS WELL AS OUR OWN AND THE
DATA THAT IS COLLECTED IS THE
DATA THAT WAS LAID OUT IN THE
VERY FIRST BILL THAT WE DID
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED TO THE
COLLECTED BY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT CUT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
ANYBODY TO SEE IT ANYTIME IT'S
RIGHT THERE ON THE STATE'S
WEBSITE- AND IT'S MOSTLY
DEMOGRAPHICS IT'S SAID THAT
IT'S DIAGNOSES- COVER
EVERYTHING UP AT THE TOP OF MY
HEAD- BUT BUT YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE IS NOT SOMEBODY WHO HAS
TO SIT THERE AND WATCH SOMEBODY
GO THAT IS NOT THAT IT. WASN'T
NOT PART OF THE BILL INITIALLY
IT'S NOT SOME IT'S BEEN FOR
LIKE IT'S INTRUSIVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE YOU KNOW DO INVITE
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AROUND TO BE
THERE WITH THEM IN THEIR FINAL
MOMENTS BUTTON NOT EVERYBODY
DOES SO- THE DATA IS WHAT WHAT
WAS LAID OUT IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE BILL AND IT IS COLLECTED
EVERY YEAR SO THE IDEA OF-
REMOVING THE SUNSET JUST WILL
LET'S JUST BE WIDE OPEN THERE
IS STILL DATA THAT IS COLLECTED
IT IS REPORTED EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND WE HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
AND CAN MAKE. ADJUSTMENTS
LATER. IF NEED. EIGHT YOU AND
M. I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- MY GRANDMOTHER PASSED
AWAY AS- THE- I CAN'T. AND IT
FOR THOSE THAT HAD. HAD LIVED
THROUGH SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO
IS. VERY FEW. ESPECIALLY AT THE
END AND SO THAT. YOU KNOW I
THINK BACK TO WHAT IT WOULD
HAVE. TO HAVE THIS OPTION-
MAYBE IT WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
EXPLORED BUT- CERTAINLY I THINK
THAT. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
EVERY INDIVIDUAL DESERVES HE TO
THINK YOU KNOW ABOUT FOR
THEMSELVES- AND I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE PUT A LOT OF THOUGHT IN
THIS I KNOW THAT MY DISTRICT
HAS HAD A LOT OF FEEDBACK ON ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE- AND- YOU
KNOW IT IS NOT AN EASY ISSUE
FOR A LOT OF FOLKS BUT I THINK
NONETHELESS. IT IS AN
INDIVIDUAL CHOICE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL GOING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS I TO ME SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
SORRY FOR THE LOSS YOU GRANDMA.
RIGHT A CENTER WIENER. BUT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- AFTER
SOLIDIFYING- CENTER ADMIN FOR
HER LONG TERM TENACIOUS WORK ON
THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND I REQUEST TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL. AND I
THINK I'M MAKING THIS PERMANENT
MAKE SENSE IS A BASIC ISSUE OF.
COMPASSION AND MERCY- AND- YOU
KNOW SOMEONE WITH THAT I WISH
WE'D DONE A LONG. TIME AGO THIS
IS NOTHING SOMETIMES YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS ABOUT-
YOU KNOW IT ARE PEOPLE GOING TO
BE PORTIONS OF THIS BY. I DON'T
THINK THAT THE RECORD ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS- I MEAN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. EVERYONE FAMILY
INDIVIDUALS MEDICAL FOR
EVERYONE TEXAS. CREDIBLY
SERIOUSLY. PEOPLE UNDER THAT
THIS IS A LIFE OR DEATH.
DECISION BUT PEOPLE IN ALSO
UNDERSTANDS. THAT FORCING
SOMEONE TO GO THROUGH THE END
STAGES OF AN UNBELIEVABLY
PAINFUL- TERMINAL MEDICAL
CONDITION JUST IF IT'S NOT
HUMANA PEOPLE SET UP OPTIONS
AND THAT IS THE COMPASSIONATE
AND MERCIFUL THING TO DO. SO I
RESPECT A LOT OF THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THIS IS A GOOD FAITH
POLICY DEBATE BUT I FALL FIRMLY
ON THE SIDE OF. A ALLOWING THIS
COMPASSION TO OCCUR AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU THE AUTHOR
FOR HER WORK. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. YES SIR
LEYVA SORRY. I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I REALLY JUST WANT TO
THANK SENATOR EGGMAN FOR HER
WORK IN THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS
AND NOW CONTINUING IN THE
SENATE I HAD JUST BEEN ELECTED
WHEN THIS BILL CAME UP AND I
REMEMBER THINKING WHILE. WE ARE
WORKING ON SOME REALLY TOUGH
STUFF HERE AND IT'S SUCH AN
EMOTIONAL ISSUE BUT IT'S SUCH
AN APARTMENT PORTANT ISSUE AND
I THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING
TO TAKE IT ON AND TO BRING US
ALL ALONG AS WELL MY MOM WENT
ALL THROUGH PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS
AND SERVER I CALLED HER AND I
SAID MOM. HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THIS AND YOU KNOW LIKE BATTLE
OF MY MOM SHE IS VERY TO THE
POINT AND BLUNT AND SHE SAID
YOU KNOW HONEY WE DON'T MAKE AN
ANIMAL SUFFER WHY WOULD WE MAKE
PEOPLE SUFFER AND I SAID WELL
THAT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
BUT I JUST THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT AND
BRING US ALL ALONG WITH YOU I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. THANK SALAS. I TO
WANT TO- ALLOW MAKE COMMENTS
MANY OF MY CALL AS WELL AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
EGGMAN I KNOW THESE ARE NOT-
EASY- PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO
PASS THROUGH BUT- I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND I THINK ALL OF US
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS
THAT WE KNOW THAT COULD HAVE.
BENEFITTED IF THAT'S EVEN YOU
KNOW AWAY IT TO FRAME IT. FROM
THIS- FROM THIS SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THEY WOULD
HAVE DIED WITH DIGNITY AND
THAT'S A THINK- THE PROMISE OF
THIS- I HAVE RECEIVED OVER
THIRTY- EMAILS FROM RESIDENTS
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL FROM
THE LONG BEACH FOR A PANTHERS
WHO ARE. CIVICALLY ACTIVE AND
ENGAGED I'M JUST LOOKING AT
THEIR TWITTER CIVICALLY ACTIVE
ENGAGING SO. YOUHAVE SUPPORT
FROM FROM MANY OF THEM SENIORS
ALL AROUND LONG BEACH IN LAKE
WOULD THAT- TRULY BELIEVE IN
THIS SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THAT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SEEING NONE-
SACRAMENTO I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS-
YOU KNOW- WHEN NAY YOU BROUGHT
THE ORIGINAL BILL I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN A SKEPTIC AND THAT MEANT I
DID NOT VOTE FOR THE BILL I.
CONCERNS BUT SAME TIME IT IS
LAW- THE ORIGINAL BILL. AND
THEY THINK THAT- IT'S CLEAR
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA ONCE AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE WORKS. AND THAT'S
WHY- I'VE KNOWN THAT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH ME TO. JUST SOME
OF THE PARAMETERS- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS RAISED
IN TERMS OF- LIKE TIMING AND SO
FORTH BUT I ALSO POINT OUT
BECAUSE I KNOW SOMEONE HAD
DONE. THAT IT'S BEEN ASKED. BUT
THERE IS THERE IS A WHOLE
PROCESS ARE A LOT OF
PROTECTIONS I MEAN THOSE ARE
PROTECTIONS ORIGINAL BILL I
DON'T THINK WE'RE WEAKENING
THOSE PROTECTIONS AT ALL. WITH
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AT THIS BILL
WHAT WE'RE MAKING IS MAKING
MORE WORKABLE FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO REALLY. DESIRE AND ONCE-
THIS OPTION. SO DAD. AGAIN I
THINK SO MUCH WORK OF THE STAFF
ABSENT CERTAINLY PERSONAL HELP
IN SUPPORT OF. THIS BILL WOULD
TO LIKE CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU
FOR MUCH AND THINK THINGS TO A
MY CALL FOR. OTHER THOUGHTFUL.
AND I KNOW IS A VERY DIFFICULT
IS DEATH IS DEATH IS THE- AT
THE BUT IS ONE THE THING THAT
WILL FACE. THAT WE WILL ALL
FACE AND- IT JUST SEEMS RIGHT
THAT WESHOULD BE ABLE TO FACE
IT ON OUR OWN TERMS. AND I'M
ALSO A PRACTICING CATHOLIC. GO
TO MASS EVERY EVERY WEEKEND
WHEN THIS CAME UP THE- THE
CHURCH REACH OUT AND WANTED TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ON THEIR
FORGET MY SCHEDULE SAID THE
BISHOP ONCE. FORTY FIVE AN HOUR
AND A HALF AND I SAID. GIVE THE
BISHOP AN HOUR AND A HALF. THE
BISHOP CARE MENU HAD FIVE OTHER
FOLKS WITH THEM AND WE DIALOGUE
AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT FOR A
LONG TIME. AND YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT YOU HAVE TO AGREE TO
DISAGREE- SO. THIS IS THIS BILL
IS NOT ABOUT SOMEBODY IS HAVING
A BAD DAY THIS BILL IS ABOUT
SOMEBODY WITH A TERMINAL
ILLNESS FACING THE END OF THEIR
LIFE. HAVING LIVED THEIR ENTIRE
LIFE AND AT THE VERY END BEING
ABLE TO DECIDE. THEIR TERMS- SO
WITHOUT AND WITH ALL OF THE
SAFEGUARDS- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
BILL. OKAY IT'S MOVE THE BILLS
MOVE BY CENTER LEYVA THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST. AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMEDIAN JUDICIARY'S
ANOTHER POLICY COMMITTEE-
CONTROLLED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAND HI CAN. HI MELINDA'S.
EIGHT HI EGGMAN ITEMS. HI AND
SALAS I GREW. GROVE NO RETIRE.
LAKE LEYVA AYE LIMóN.
SIMILARLY SPT EIGHTY I MON I
ROTH ARE ROTH AYE RUBIO. WIENER
HI WIENER AYE. SEVEN ONE. SEVEN
ONE OKAY THE BILL'S CURRENTLY
SEVEN ONE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR AT ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN AND I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL
BEFORE US HERE- SO ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB FIVE OH SEVEN- PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
STILL HERE I AM NOT PRESENT SB
FIVE OH SEVEN A BILL THAT WILL
MAKE REVISIONS. TO ON LPS LAST
YEAR. I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT AND
RECOMMENDED THE ANALYSIS TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE SUBJECT OF
A HEARING MAINTAIN THE RIGHT TO
APPEAR. IN COURT IN PERSON IF
THEY SHOULD CHOOSE. THE STATE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT INDIVIDUALS.
EXITING INVOLUNTARY HOLDS BUT
HAVE NOT BEEN ROLLED
CONSEQUENTLY IN SUBSEQUENT CARE
TO HELP THEM TRANSITION SAFELY
INTO THEIR COMMUNITY AND KEEP
THEM CONNECTED TO VITAL
RESOURCES. ROUGHLY ONE IN FOUR
PEOPLE PLACED ON
CONSERVATORSHIP CYCLE BACK TO
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS. DESPITE
HAVING SUCCESSFULLY RECOVERED.
YOUR ABILITY TO CARE FOR THEIR
BASIC NEEDS WHEN THEY EXITED
CONSERVATORSHIP. UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW TO QUALIFY FOR
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT A
PERSON'S. CONDITION MUST BE
SUBSTANTIALLY DETERIORATING.
THIS CRITERION. SINCE WE
PROHIBITS THOSE EXITING MORE
RESTRICTIVE TREATMENT SETTINGS
FROM ACCESSING AOTI EVEN THOUGH
THEY MAY BENEFIT FROM THE
SERVICES. THIS BILL REVISES
ELIGIBILITY ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THAT IT APPEARS
REASONABLY LIKELY THAT THEY
WILL BE AT SIGNIFICANT RISK FOR
DETERMINATION BASED ON THEIR
TREATMENT HISTORY AND CURRENT
BEHAVIOR. WE WANT COUNTIES TO
BE ABLE TO OFFER PROVIDE A. O.
T. PROGRAMS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
CONTINUED TREATMENT AND ACCESS
TO RESOURCES TO KEEP THEM IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE EXAM OR
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF WHERE
THE DEFENDANT HAS CAPACITY TO
GIVE INFORMED CONSENT.
REGARDING PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS WE KNOW THAT IT
HURTS TO TAKING MEDICATION IS A
CRUCIAL COMPONENT. TO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RECOVERY. HOWEVER
CURRENT LAW EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITS A. O. T. PLANTS FROM
INCLUDING. INVOLUNTARY
MEDICATION. ALLOWING THE
EXAMINER TO DISCUSS THE SUBJECT
OF MEDICATION DURING THE
HEARING IS A SMALL STEP TOWARD
INITIATING A DIALOGUE ABOUT THE
PATIENT'S CAPACITY. TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY NEED
MEDICATION. ESTABLISHING THIS
CONVERSATION DURING THE HEARING
WILL ALSO ENSURE. THAT IT IS
DOCUMENTED IN THE PATIENT'S
MEDICAL FILE WHICH CAN THEN BE
REFERENCED DURING FUTURE
MEDICATION COMPLIANCE CON
CONVERSATIONS. WITH MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. FINALLY
THE BILL INCORPORATES A
RECOMMEND RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE AUDITOR TO ALLOW
APPEARANCE. BEFORE THE COURT
FOR TESTIMONY BY EXAMINING
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER BY VIDEO
CONFERENCING. DO NOT CALL OUT
ANY ON IT THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE SUBJECT OF THE PETITION
TO ALSO APPEAR. VIA VIDEO IF
THEY CHOOSE AND THEY RIPPED
RETAIN THE RIGHT TO BE PRESENT
AT THE HEARING. THE SPEND
IMMIGRATION IS ALL THAT HAVING
THE ABILITY TO USE TECHNOLOGY
TO COMMUNICATE IS CRUCIAL WE
WANT THIS ACCESS TO CONTINUE
LONG AFTER THIS PANDEMIC IS
ENDED. OUR CURRENT MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM ISN'T WORKING I
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN BOTH HOUSES ARE
WORKING TIRELESSLY ON POLICIES
TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM. I TALK
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
WE ARE EXPERIENCING LAST YEAR
WERE PRESENTING AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX WE ARE STILL IN A
CRISIS IN THE PANDEMIC IS STILL
GOING ON. WE NEED SOLUTIONS TO
IMPROVE OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND RESOURCES. A. O.
T. WORKS IT INCREASES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE ONE'S
QUALITY OF LIFE. IT INCREASES
THE CHANCES FOR RECOVERY. FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCING SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS. IT SAVES LIVES
AND IT KEEPS PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY IN A LESS
RESTRICTIVE. SETTING UP WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS OUR SPONSOR
RANDALL HAGAR FOR WITH THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND CAROL STENCH
FILLED THE DIRECTOR OF A. O. T.
SERVICES AT TURNING POINT.
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS IN NEVADA
COUNTY. THANK YOU SENATOR NOW
LET'S BRING ON THE MODERATE
PLEASE BRING ON THE WITNESS IS
A SUPPORT RAYNAUD HAGER- FROM
THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA AND CAROL
STANCHFIELD. TURNING POINT
COMMITTEE PROGRAMS- MIDDLE
HAGAR OF A SINISTER ONLINE GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TOTAL FOUR MINUTES FOR
BOTH WITNESSES. YES MISTER
CHAIR- I'D LIKE THAT GIRL
SCHEDULED TO START PLEASE OKAY
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH THE CARE CENTER FIELD.
PLEASE BEGIN. HELLO MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- AND CAROL
STANFIELD DIRECTOR OF ETIENNE
ACT SERVICES FOR TURNING POINT
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THAT AND HE
DOES WORK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO WE AT
TURNING POINT PARTNERED WITH
SYNTHETIC COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FIRST DAY
OF DEPROGRAMMING CALIFORNIA THE
PROGRAM SERVING PEOPLE WITH
SEVERE PSYCHIATRIC DISORDER
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS THOSE
WITH THE GREATEST NEED. PEOPLE
WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE
ENGAGING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT DESPITE THE SEVERITY
OF THEIR ILLNESS AOTEA DOWN
UPON. IT AND STATE PRACTICE OF.
ASSERTIVE COMMITTEE TO. OUTCOME
EFFECTIVELY DEMONSTRATE
REDUCTIONS IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
INCARCERATIONS HOMELESSNESS AND
CRISIS CONTACT. IT IS FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED A NARROW LIST
OF CRITERIA FOR ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT AND FILL
THIS GAP IN THE TREATMENT
CONTINUUM OF CARE. AOTEA
PROACTIVE PROVIDING THE ABILITY
TO MONITOR AND IT JUST SERVICES
QUICKLY TO PREVENT FURTHER
DECOMPENSATION FOR CRISIS EVENT.
WE SERVE THOSE WHO LACK-
INSIGHT WE HAVE A SEVERE LACK
OF INSIGHT INTO THEIR ILLNESS
THERE FOR LACK OF CAPACITY TO
ENGAGE IN TREATMENT VOLUNTARILY
DESPITE REPEATED OFFERS OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. COST
SAVINGS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
THE REDUCTION OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH REPEATED CRISIS
HOSPITALIZATION AND OTHER
EMERGENCY INTERVENTION. HE SAID
FLY HUNDRED. RECOVERY AND HOPE.
PEOPLE CAN GET BETTER WE HAVE
SEEN THE POSITIVE EFFECTS OF
WARS WHILE THE CLIENT THEIR
PARENTS FAMILIES FRIENDS AND
THE COMMUNITY ITSELF- HERE AND
WHERE LAWRENCE LINE IS.
IMPLEMENTED THE RIVER RECEIVED-
THE END OF THAT COUNTY AND
EIGHTY SIX THE TRADITION
RESULTING IN SEVENTY COURT
ORDERS OR SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
TWO MINUTES. HM BROUGH THROUGH
THE- AOTI PROCESS HAVE AVERAGE
OF TO SIX PEOPLEPER YEAR- HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM MAYO T. I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
EXPERIENCES LAWRENCE LAW AND DO
IT AND WHAT IS POSSIBLE. WHEN
WE PROVIDE HELP TO INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES SUFFER
AS A RESULT OF UNTREATED SEVERE
PSYCHIATRIC ILLNESS. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NOTES
WITH ON TO RANDALL HAGER YOU
GOT A MINUTE AND A HALF NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM RIGHT
OKAY GREAT YOU REPRESENT THE
PSYCHIATRIC POSITIONS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO
START OUT WITH THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW TNCS DEVICE. HAS AS
THE LPS AUDITORS REPORT DOES
RECOMMEND HAS ALREADY BEEN USED
AS A STEP DOWN OR TRANSITION-
TOOL FOR PEOPLE SUCCESSFULLY TO
GROW TO LOWER LEVELS OF KERR-
AND SOLD THEY'RE SORT OF
ALREADY APPROVED THE CONCEPT L.
A. COUNTY VERY EARLY.
IMPLEMENTATION A. O. T. AS A
TOOL USED TO USE THAT TO WILL
TO TRANSITION PEOPLE PROBLEM
TWENTY HOURS THE COUNTY JAIL
INTO THE COMMUNITY THE RESULTS
ARE VERY ENCOURAGING. IN WAYS
THAT ANTICIPATED WHAT THE
AUDITOR WOULD COME TO
RECOMMEND- SO WHEN THE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDS A STEP DOWN THESE
ARE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE FAIL- AFTER LEAVING
CONSERVATORSHIP SUNTAN IN BEING
IN THE COMMUNITY WITHOUT
STRUCTURE. FOR TREATMENT AND
WHOSE HISTORY YOU KNOW- OTHERS
FOR WHOSE HISTORY- DETAIN THEM
FOR SHORT PERIODS OF- REPEATED
HOLDS. ANY INPATIENT SETTINGS
AND YOU KNOW THEY ALSO NEED A
I'M MORE MORE STRUCTURE IN
TREATMENT THE COMMUNITY SO YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT S. B. SEVEN
B. AS HAS MANAGED TO VERY.
NEVER NARAL WE TAILOR A
SOLUTION TO THE NEEDS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH RESPECT TO THE
FACT THAT THEY SIMPLY WE
SQUEEZE WITH SIMPLY TWEAKED ONE
OF THE CRITERIA THE CRITERIA
CURRENT. PATIENT NOW ALLOWS
THOSE WHO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL RISK
OF DETERIORATION OR REASONABLY.
LIKELY TO DETERIORATE. I WAS
BENEFIT FROM- D. OUT TREATMENT
YOU DAY I ANY. THANK YOU SIR
MUCH- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN- THE NAME- AT
SOLUTION AND POSITION AND I
SOME WALKING OVER FROM THE
GALLERY. OKAY WELCOME THANK YOU
DOCTOR PANEL OF MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE ERIN
LEHANE ON BEHALF OF THE NEARLY
HALF A MILLION MEMBERS. OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THE EXPANSION OF LAUREL FLOORS
LAW. SB FIVE OH SEVEN WE
APPRECIATE CENTER ADMINS
COMMITMENT TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR STATE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU SEEN OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S
ROOM MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SAY NO ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
TO WITNESSES WHO WAS
TESTIFYING. IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE OH SEVEN AGAIN IT'S NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN
THE ROW. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND A LINE NINETEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CALL YOUR
ARMY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS A- HELLO
TERRY MEMBERS MRS CALLS WORSE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE FORTY ONE YOUR MY GET UP
AND. ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR MIKE AT
THE- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS WILL BE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTED SB FIVE
OF SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXLINE. AND MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANKS VERY MUCH NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE OH SEVEN WE DO NOT HAVE
A LEAD TO OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH
THE PUBLIC GALLERY. SAY KNOWN
AT THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SAY
NO IN A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
TELEPHONIC LINE TO. PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FIVE A
SEVEN. CAN NAME ASSOCIATION AND
POSITION. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE NO COMMENT
OKAY YES NOW THAT WE'VE
CONCLUDED- PUBLIC TESTIMONY OR
TO ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEING NONE AND ONE WAY
OUT YES CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BROKE QUICKLY I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- OF
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESSES LIKE A
DOMINO EFFECT YOU KNOW IT
AFFECTS SO MANY OTHER AREAS OF
OUR- COMMUNITY- YOU KNOW AS A
PERTAINS TO HOMELESSNESS
FAMILIES THAT STRUGGLE WITH
THAT I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
BILL THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S ONE
SMALL STEP IN TRYING TO GET THE
PEOPLE TO HELP THAT THEY NEED
AND SO I WOULD LOVE TO NOT ONLY
SUPPORTED THAT THE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AS
WELL. FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. AT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I SEE NO
ONE ELSE MICROPHONE UP AND IT'S
IN THE HANDS UP. SIR IVAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR THE BILL
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENT TO ENSURE THAT THE
PERSONAL PROPERTY TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON- THE PERSON WHO DID THIS
TO US. I THINK IS IMPORTANT-
STEP TO TRYING TO- SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET THE TREATMENT
THEY NEED- SELF WHICH I CLOSE.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GLAD
TO. AT THE SENATOR AS A CO
AUTHOR UNDERSTOOD TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THIS IS AN AREA
THAT WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE DOING
WORK IN AND I KNOW IT IT HERE
ANOTHER BILL FROM OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM OUR END AND WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE THESE BILLS ARE IN
CONFLICT AND ALL WORK VERY WELL
TOGETHER- AND SO- JUST I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EITHER OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN TO THE MOTIONS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER RUBIO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED. THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ANOTHER
ONE GOING OUT TO JUDICIARY A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI CAN I AM MELINDA'S
LINDA'S I EGGMAN BY EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I GROW
HER TADO LEYVA. LIMON SENATOR
LEAVING MONNING SB FIVE OH
SEVEN RIGHT. LIMON I ROTH. ROTH
AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE WIENER.
RIGHT WIENER I AT LEAST. EIGHT
THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS EIGHT
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS HE CENTER
EGGMAN I SEE SARAH GLACIER
WELCOME- SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BY SEVEN- GLACIER
WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU
CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THE BILL
EXCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- YOU YOU
HEARD- JUST A MOMENT AGO ABOUT
SB FIVE A SEVEN ANOTHER
TERRIFIC. BILL THAT YOU'RE
MOVING FORWARD DIED TODAY THIS
BILL- IT'S SIMILAR IT'S
COMPLIMENTARY I APPLAUD ALL
THOSE WORKING IN THIS SPACE AND
I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
COORDINATION AND COMMUNICATION
STILL TO BE DONE BUT THIS IS A
BILL SB SEVENTY TWO IS THE
RESULT OF FINDINGS FROM THE
AUDIT BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR- LAST JULY. OF TWENTY
TWENTY. HI ON THE AUDIT AND
THEIR- IT- CLARIFIES THAT THOSE
WHO WERE- WERE EXITING WHO
RECENTLY EXITED. CONSERVATOR
SHIPS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO BE
PLACED IN THIS INVOLUNTARY
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT.
CURRENTLY COURTS CAN ORDER
CONSERVATOR SHIPS ONLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND THOSE WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
BASIC NEEDS. HOWEVER AFTER
RECEIVING TREATMENT AND EXITING
CONSERVATORSHIP. INDIVIDUALS
ARE OFTEN NOT. CONNECTED TO
CONTINUE CARE AS YOU HEARD IS
THAT IT DURING THE DISCUSSION
OF SB FIVE OF SEVEN. AND WHEN
THIS HAPPENS DAY RELAPSE AND
NEED CONSERVATIVE SHIPS AGAIN.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT ONE IN FOUR
INDIVIDUALS WHO OF THE ACCIDENT
CONSERVATORSHIP SWEAR PLACED.
BACK IN CONSERVATORSHIP AGAINDESPITE HAVING BEEN DEEMED TO
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY RECOVERED-
PREVIOUSLY. ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT IS USED BY COUNTIES
PROVIDE CARE IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING. ENSURES
THAT INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
SERVICES SUCH AS PSYCHIATRIC
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AT THE- AND
ASSISTANCE WITH HOUSING. THE
STATE AUDITOR RECOMMENDED THAT
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
BE USED WHEN APPROPRIATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXITING
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS. BUT AS THE
AUTHORS NOTED THIS IS NOT
POSSIBLE UNDER CURRENT LAW. AS
AS YOU HAVE HEARD THE CRITERIA
FOR ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT SERVICES EXCLUDES
THESE INDIVIDUALS- TO RESOLVE
THIS CONTRADICTION THIS BILL
ADOPTS THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR BY ALLOWING
THE COURT TO ORDER AN
INDIVIDUAL EXITING CONSERVATIVE
SHIPS TO OBTAIN ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT. IF THE
COURTS FIND THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THAT
TREATMENT- THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
COUNTIES TO USE THE- ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT AS A STEP
DOWN FORM OF CARE AS
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITION TO
LIVING INDEPENDENTLY. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY FAVORITES TERRA
GAMBLE- EASTMAN OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE- AND I
WOULD WELCOME HER TESTIMONY TO
THE CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH- CENTER GLACIER.
MODERATE PLEASE BRING ON TERRA
GAMBLE EASTMAN FROM STEINBERG
INSTITUTE AND WHEN YOU'RE ON-
PLEASE BEGIN TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
HIS HER AGAIN THOUGH EACH THEN
WITH THE FEINBERG INSTITUTE AN
INDEPENDENT NON PROFIT PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE. AND SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY ON THE ISSUE THE
BRAIN HEALTH I JUST LIKE A STAR
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
ATTRACTING SHOULD THE BRAIN
HEALTH TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING TO IMPORTANT. AND
COMPETITOR EGGMAN FOR HER ON A
FIVE OH SEVEN WE ARE THRILLED
BE. ANYTHING FOR THAT ON A HE
TODAY'S AND WILL KEEP MY ARE AT
THE OF THE HAD BEEN SAID
BUCKLEY HIGHLIGHTED. OUR
CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH WITHIN
PUT CAL. WITH DURING MENTAL
ILLNESS DURING EXPENSE AND
TRAUMA. FOR THE DOOR AT THE
BETWEEN OUR- AND MERGING THE
ROOM AND ST. IN BOND HOLDS AND
CAN. HER OFF VIEW AS A WAY SAVE.
INTO THE- AND BREAK THAT BY.
BUT IS BOTH THE AUTHOR AND
EDITOR EGGMAN HAS SPOKEN ABOUT
TODAY. PLEASE ENTER. OFTEN FAIL
OVER TIME BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE LAST WITHOUT THE
TRANSITIONAL AND LONG TERM
SUPPORT THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
FACILITATE BAND. LEVINE
INDEPENDENTLY AND SAFELY IN THE
COMMUNITY. OUR GOAL SHOULD
ALWAYS BE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE IN
ACCESSING THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
TREATMENT HELLO. ADHD IS AN
EFFECTIVE. BASED BACKGROUND
APPROACH THAT HELPS PREVENT
FUTURE CONSERVATORSHIP. BY
INCREASING ALCOHOL. KITA THOSE
EXITING CONSERVATORSHIP. SB
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO TAKE A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD IN
BREAKING THE CYCLE. BE. IT IF
YOU. RUBIO THE POOR AT AT SEVEN
EIGHTY RESPECTFUL REQUEST AND I.
THE YOU. THANK YOU- BUT THAT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS TEST
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWO- WILL
BEGIN THE PUBLIC SAY NONE LET'S
MOVE TO RE TWENTY. SAYING NO I
OF MY PLEASE BRING ON TELL LINE.
WITNESSES WHO WAS TESTIFYING
SUPPORT OF THIS BE SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO AND THAT'S NAY. AFFILIATE
AND DOES ON THE- THANK YOU
MEDICARE FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE ONE COMMENT
COMING FOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE GATHER THEIR LINE.
THANK YOU. AN ONLINE ONE
HUNDRED THREE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN RANDALL
BAKER AGAIN FOR THIS
PSYCHIATRIC POSITIONS ALLIANCE
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU EXLINE. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT I THANK
YOU MODERATOR LET'S NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY SO
LET'S GO MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE OR THE PUBLIC
GALLAGHER LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. THAT'S NOW MOVES
TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
TO WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO AND GET ITS NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE-
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. TO
SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND THE O. LINE TWENTY FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS UP YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TYLER IN THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE NOT IN
OPPOSITION PERHAPS CONCERNS AND
SUBMITTED A LETTER ON THE BACK
AND RECORDED DISCUSSION THANK
YOU OKAY DO YOU WISH TO
LEVERAGE TO PERHAPS I'LL GIVE
YOU A LITTLE TIME TO LEVERAGE
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE AN
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON THAT
TOP. THAT THAT CONCERN. SURE
WHERE I'M SORRY ABOUT NOT
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
COMMITTEE BEFOREHAND YEAH WE
ARE YOU KNOW CONCERNED DECIDED
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THAT
FITS WITH EXISTING COUNTY
PRACTICE THEN- ON THE WAY TO DO
WELL WE'VE HAD TO CUT STARTED
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND CAN ELABORATE ON.
YOU KNOW FURTHER AT THAT TIME
WHEN I DON'T SEE HOW THE BILL
STATES WITH EXISTING COUNTY
PRACTICES WHICH- YOU KNOW WILL
DOUBLE AND BEING PART OF A
CONSERVATORSHIP AS THEY STEP
DOWN- BY THE FACTO. CENTRALLY
IN DANTE. WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
IS. LOOKING LIKE THEY'RE
RECOVERING NO LONGER GOING TO
BE GRAVELY DISABLED IT IS
COMMON COUNTY PRACTICE TO BRING
THE PERSON BACK TO THE- COUNTY
AT THEIR IN AND OUT OF COUNTY
POLICEMAN. HAVE THEM AND I
LOCKED IN A RESIDENTIAL OR-
OTHER TYPE OF STANDING AND THEN
HOP ON. THE INDIVIDUAL- B.
MONITORED AND- BEFORE THEY'RE
RELEASED FROM THEIR
CONSERVATORSHIP AND SO WE WANT
TO SEE HOW THE BILL I MEAN HAVE
FOR THEIR CONVERSATION POWER
STATEMENT EXISTING COUNTY
PRACTICE AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSIONS ON THE BILL BUT WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO IT OKAY.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MODERATOR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO. INVESTORS ARE
FURTHER COMMENT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU MONTEREY THAT'LL MOVE
TO COMMITTEE THERE QUESTIONS
ARE COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. HEY
SEEING NONE NO HAN UP HERE.
ASSEMBLY ON THE FIRST OF ALL
THANKYOU FOR WORKING WITH OUR
STAFF AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS- APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THE BILL-
IDEAS- IN YOUR CLOTHES PERHAPS
YOU CAN ADDRESS. HOW YOU
WORKING WITH THE- I GUESS A
LETTER OF CONCERN IF NOT
OPPOSITION. TO ADDRESS THEIR
ISSUES BUT- CERTAINLY ILL BE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY SO
CENTER GLAZER. I THANK EACH
YEAR PAN. YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THE EACH OF US HAVE HAD FRIENDS
OF THE FAMILY. OTHERS THAT HAVE
FALL INTO THIS MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT- HAS TOUCH OUR
LIVES AND THAT I CERTAINLY
HAVE. FELT THAT PERSONALLY- AND
CERTAINLY THE PANDEMIC HAS MADE
THINGS SAYS- SO MUCH SO MUCH
WORSE- ADDED THAT- ANGST AND
CONCERN- NOT ONLY BE AN ACTIVE
LAST YEAR LAST SESSION AND THAT
IN THIS SPACE BUT- I'VE OFFERED
THREE DIFFERENT BILLS- IN THE
SPACE ONE ON FUNDING. TO WANT
OVERSIGHT AND THIS BILL ON
REFORM. AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MANY MEMBERS ON THIS FOR
CERTAINLY THE SENATOR FROM
STOCKTON AND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. AND OTHERS ARE
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO.
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO. TAKE
CONSTRUCTIVE STEPS TO DO WHAT
WE ALL KNOW NEEDS TO HAPPEN
WHICH IS TO DO. TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS- I COMMEND THOSE
UP ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SIDE IN OUR COUNTIES. THAT ARE
WORKING SO HARD HAVE BEEN. I
APPRECIATE THE LET OF CONCERN
THAT HAVE A- ANYTHING THAT- WE
HAVE A LOOK AT TO HAVE
CONSTRUCTIVE. TO TRY TO FIND A-
A GOOD PATH FORWARD. AND I
THINK WITH YOUR HELP OF MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
DO THAT- AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY OKAY THANK YOU
WESTERN GLAZIERS- MOTION ON
THIS BILL. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER EGGMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE- FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THAT'S
HOME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HAN
HI HANNAH AYE MELINDA'S AYE
LINDA'S AYE EGGMAN. HI EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HER TADO. LEYVA ALL
LEYVA AYE LIMóN. SENATOR LEE
MULLIN STC EIGHT HI LIMON I
ROTH. ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER HI.
OKAY THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
WILL HOLD THE GIRL OPENED FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH
CENTER GLACIER THANK YOU RIGHT-
NEXT ITEM UP TO AS AND I'M
NUMBER SIX IS ON CONSENT NEXT
TIME UP IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN BY
CENTER LEYVA IF YOU WANT TO
FIGHT FOR YOUR DESK HI I HOPE
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND TRYING
NOT STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO SURGEONS
TO. LET THE ABSENT MEMBERS KNOW
THAT- THIS IS WE CONCLUDE THIS
BILL WILL BE VOTING ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN
OPENING THE ROLE. FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SO CENTER LEYVA.
LOADING FIGURE MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
SB FOUR FIFTY FIVE WOULD EXTEND
COVERED CALIFORNIA IS A RULE OF
MERCHANTS HE RULE MAKING.
AUTHORITY FOR ITS REGULATORY
PACKAGES. UNTIL JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THIS BILL
FALLS UP ON MY PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION SB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE. FROM TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT EXTENDED COVER
CALIFORNIA'S. EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING UNTIL JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. DOING COVER
CALIFORNIA'S RULE MAKING
AUTHORITY IS SET TO EXPIRE. AND
EVOLVING LANDSCAPE IN HEALTH
CARE S. B. FOUR FIFTY FIVE
WOULD PROVIDE. COVER CALIFORNIA
THE FLEXIBILITY NEEDED TO
COMPLY WITH ONGOING CHANGES. TO
FEDERAL AND STATE POLICIES. THE
RECENT TRANSITION TO A NEW
ADMINISTRATION. ONGOING
PROPOSALS RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND POLICY
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. WOULD
REQUIRE COVERED CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE AND IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENT.
REGULATIONS QUICKER THAN
THROUGH THE PERMANENT
RULEMAKING PROCESS. EVOLVING
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES
COULD IMPACT ELIGIBILITY.
ENROLLMENT AND OTHER AREAS OF
COVERED CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
EMERGENCY RULE MAKING
AUTHORITY. TO BE EXTENDED
BEYOND JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WITHOUT THIS
EMERGENCY RULEMAKING COVER
CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS COULD
CONFLICT WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
POLICIES AND ULTIMATELY TO LACK
OF ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE FOR FAMILIES. MEMBERS SB
FOUR FIFTY FIVE HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND GIVES COVERED
CALIFORNIA THE FLEXIBILITY
NEEDED TO RESPOND TO ANNUAL AND
EMERGENCY CHANGES AND FEDERAL
AND STATE RULES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA.
MODERATOR WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WHO ARE TESTIFYING SUPPORT A
KELLY GREEN FROM CONCORD
CALIFORNIA AND BRANDON ROSS
FROM COVERED CALIFORNIA KEEP
PLEASE BRING THEM ON THE LINE
AND- YES WILL START AT. LEAST
AFTER THE GREEN FIRST SELF-
KELLY GREEN COULD GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN TO MINUTES- PER. WITNESS
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER.
I'LL GET UNDER CENTER LEYVA
YEAH I APOLOGIZE THEY'RE BOTH
HERE FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT OF
THEIR QUESTIONS THEY WILL BE
HERE TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
OKAY SO DID NOT PROVIDE FORMAL.
TESTIMONY OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING OF- LET'S NOW- THEN MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT WILL MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SING ROOM. OWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIFTY
FIVE AND NAME AFFILIATION
POSITION. THANK YOU MEDICARE
FOR COMMON IN SUPPORT THAT SB
FOUR FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. THEN ZERO. BACK AMANDA CAN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR I
SHOW NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR LET'S
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AGAIN
WE DO NOT HAVE US ON FORMALLY
LISTED FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE- IN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY THAT'S MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE TO TELEPHONIC LINE
PLEASE ALLOW WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR FIFTY FIVE- TO TESTIFY
TELEPHONICALLY AND AGAIN IT'S
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE IF THAT NERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE TEN ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU- NOW LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE CENTER RUBIO LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED YES CENTER
GROVE. HERE CAN YOU GIVE ME
JUST ONE SECOND TO. YES I
APOLOGIZE I'M BOUNCING BETWEEN
COMMITTEES I DO APOLOGIZE AND-
I SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I DO
HAVE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I DO
HAVE ONE CONCERN ABOUT IT AND
IS THERE ANY CONCERN WITH YOU
THAT WE'RE GIVING THE AOL OR
SEEN THE- ALE JUST UNFETTERED
AUTHORITY- TO RENEW THIS
EMERGENCY REGULATORY PROCESS
AND WITHOUT ANY LIMITATIONS ON
A CAP USUALLY IT'S JUST YOU CAN
DO IT TWICE- BUT THERE'S NO CAP
NOW IN THE JUST. THE A WILL CAN
DO IT FOR THE SEASON- A- CAN DO
IT WHO'S THE OIL OF THE OFFICE
OF THE OMBUDSMAN AND I WILL IS
LIVE ANALYSTS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST GOT IT I'M
THRILLED HISTORY OF LAW I
BELIEVE NO OFFICE OF ISRAEL YES
SORRY OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE CLARIFICATIONS I WISH I
WOULD HAVE. BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE HAD IT ON THE PAGE BEFORE
I LEFT FOR THE OTHER COMMITTEE
HEY OKAY I THINK THAT THERE IS
A LIMITATION I DIDN'T NOT KNOW
THERE WAS A RULE OR MAYBE AN
UNWRITTEN RULE THAT YOU CAN
ONLY DO IT ONCE OR TWICE BUT
THAT'S WHY WE'RE EXTENDING THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS AGAIN WE
EXTENDED IT IN TWO THOUSAND.
EIGHTEEN AND NOW AND SERVE JUST
EXTENDING IT FOR THREE YEARS
WE'RE GOING TO EXTEND IT FOR
FIVE YEARS JUST TO GIVE THEM
THE FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THE MOST. COVER
CALIFORNIANS CAN BE COVERED.
AND I GET MY GUESS MAKE. IS A I
APPRECIATE THAT LIKE I SAY I DO
SUPPORT IT I JUST HAD CONCERNS
BASICALLY WITH WITH THAT AND
ALSO UNDER THE EMERGENCY ORDERS.
I MEAN IT'S- TRANSIT
TRANSPARENCY THAT I'M SEEKING
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THINGS LIKE
THAT UNDER. A REGULAR. A
REGULATIONS WHEN THEY GET PAST
THERE'S A FORTY FIVE DAY PUBLIC
COMMENT. PERIOD AND UNDER
EMERGENCY. REGULATIONS THAT ARE
PASTORS ONLY A FIVE DAY PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD SO- I GUESS I
HAD. CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE AND I ALSO
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT- JUST
ELIMINATING THE CAP COMPLETELY
SO- BUT I SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYTHING
GETS DONE IN A PROCESS. AND WE
HAVE TO CONFORM WITH FEDERAL.
POLICY THAT CONSTANTLY CHANGES.
AND YOU KNOW WE ARE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT IN THE STATE SO. I DO
I JUST HAVE THOSE CONCERNS AND-
THIS EXTENDS IT FOR FIVE YEARS
IT DOESN'T COMPLETELY ELIMINATE
WHAT CAP. WELL AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BASED ON THE
ANALYSIS THAT I HAVE AND THE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU CAN
AND RENEW THEIR MERCY
REGULATIONS. TWICE OKAY A BIT
THIS ALLOWS THEM TO THAT WERE
MOVING THAT CAP YEAH THE
ACCORDING TO OFFICE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW THAT THERE
WERE ELIMINATING THAT CAP TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT MORE THAN TWICE
GOTCHA I SEE OKAY YES WE ARE
THAT IS CORRECT. I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO TALK WITH YOU MORE
OFFLINE IF THAT IS HELPFUL US
SENATOR GROUP BUT I CAN ALSO
GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE UNDER THE
EMERGENCY OF RULEMAKING IF
THAT'S HELPFUL IN THE
TRANSPARENCY PIECE BUT I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THE NUMBER OF DAYS- IN REGULAR
RULEMAKING VERSUS THE EMERGENCY
RULE MAKING IS THAT CORRECT.
YES BECAUSE IF YOU KNOW PUBLIC
COMMENT IT TAKES AND WE ALL
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS AND PEOPLE
AROUND SACRAMENTO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS BUT IT TAKES AWHILE TO
GET BACK TO OUR DISTRICTS WHERE
PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE COMMENT ON
CERTAIN THINGS. AND I THINK
HEALTHCARE IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT OVER AND
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND ALL OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO HAVE COMMENT ON
IT BURNUP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. RIGHT AND ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
RIGHT ACTUALLY. THE CERTAINLY
THE I WOULD MAKE NO THAT
ACTUALLY A PRIOR BILL THAT YOU
AUTHORED WHICH I BELIEVE FOR
EXTENDING THE DEADLINE FOR
ACTUALLY SAYS THAT WHILE WE AND
THAT PRIOR BILL ACTUALLY
REMOVED. THE T. A CAP ON THE
TWO BUT- IN EXCHANGE REQUIRES
THAT ANY CHANGES BE ACTUALLY
ANNOUNCED AT A BOARD MEETING
WHICH IT HAS TO BE PUBLIC.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A BOARD COVER
CALIFORNIA BOARD. REGULATIONS
BE PRESENTED AND THEN IT HAS TO
BE AT THE SUBSEQUENT BOARD
MEETING. A BEFORE CAN BE
ADOPTED SO THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND PUBLIC ANNOUNCEMENT OF
INTENDED EMERGENCY REGULATION
BY THE COVER CALIFORNIA BOARD-
SO THAT JUST AN OBSERVATION I
WOULD MAKE- AND- IN TERMS OF
BEING SURE THAT WE HAVE- PEOPLE
CAN. ACTUALLY COME IN THE GAUGE
ON IT- BEFORE ADOPTION. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAM I APPRECIATE
YOU REMEMBERING MY OF HER
LEGISLATION BETTER THAN I DO
THINK HE'LL- WELL. I JUST
WANTED BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
RAISED US SO- BUT CERTAINLY
THANK YOU SAID I THINK THAT
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO BE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE. PATIENCE PLANS
PROVIDERS OTHER PEOPLE BEING
CAUGHT UP. IN A IN A JAM
BETWEEN FEDERAL REGULATIONS
WHICH MAY HAVE TO CHANGE OUR
LAWS. AND THE STATE SO THAT WE
ACHIEVE THE ATTENDS AND SO WITH
THAT I CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AN
EARLY. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
LEYVA- IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER. TO CHECK NO FOR. THE
BOND. ON THE- COMPUTER. ALL
RIGHT- SO- CENTER RUBIO'S MOVED
BILL TO DO PASSED THE FIRST BE
REFERRED. TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN. HI
CAN I AM A- I LINDA'S AYE A-
EGGMAN I CAN SALAS HI AND SO I.
GROWTH BY TOTEM AND- A TOTAL BY
LEYVA HI LEYVA LIMóN. SAN
LIMON S. B. FOUR FIVE FIVE HI
LIMON I ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE WIENER HI WIENER AYE.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT ELEVEN ZERO
ALL RIGHT- AND WITH THAT LET'S
NOW MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE ONLY ONE ITEM ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S S.
B. SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY HUESO IN
THE MOTION THERE'S TO PASS BUT
REFER TO THE COMMUNITY SHARING-
SO IS OUR MOTION CONSENT
CALENDARS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
EGGMAN I SAID A CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. HAND HI PAN
HI MELINDA'S SIDE MELENDEZ AYE
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE AGAIN
SALAS AYE AND SALAS I DROVE.
HER TODD. HI INTERTOTO LEYVA.
ALL LEYVA HI LIMóN. SENATOR
LIMóN CONSENT CALENDAR I LIMON
I ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER. WIENER I GROOVE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. PROVI
THANK YOU TO SEND DOLLARS OUT
ELEVEN ZERO NOW LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH THE FILE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SO WE'LL JUST GO IN THE
ORDER IN WHICH WE'VE HEARD SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE HOLD ON LET ME GO
GET MY PAPER STRAIGHTENED OUT
HERE. PAGE NOT HER. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE IS SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE BY SARAH COVER
YELLOW SIX THREE PLEASE DON'T
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS HER TADO AYE HURTADO
AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE OKAY
THE BILL IS ALEX ELEVEN ZERO
NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE BY SARAH
CAPPIELLO. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT'S NUMBER ZERO HI
GROUP I HER TITLE AND HER TADO
I RUBIO RUBIO AYE THAT BILLS
OUT ELEVEN ZERO NEXT BILLS ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB THREE EIGHTY BY
CENTER EGGMAN SIX CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS. MELENDEZ HURTADO NINE
FOR TOTAL RUBIO. I HAVE EIGHT
ONE. WHAT STEP THOSE OUT EIGHT
ONE- NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB FIVE A SEVEN BY CENTER
EGGMAN- SECURITIES CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS. GROSS HI
GROVE I HER TADO FOR TOTAL AYE
LEYVA. ALL LEYVA HI THAT BILLS
OUT ELEVEN ZERO NEXT ITEMS I'M
NUMBER FIVE SB SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR GLAZERS CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
GROW. HI GROVE I HER TITLE AND
HER TOTAL AYE THAT BILL IS OUT
ELEVEN ZERO BELIEVE THAT
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR THIS-
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH THEY WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN OF ALL THE
PHONE CALLS AND- ERA AND ALSO
WANTING MY COMMITTEE STAFF- IF
THERE'S PEOPLE I MAKE. COMMENTS
THAT DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PLEASE FEEL FREE TO. GO TO
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND MAKE YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
ANY OF THE BILLS THAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY. AND WITH THAT- SEE
NO OTHER ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.